because I know Pink and I know that Pink has a lot of uh mental
health issues. So, I would not be surprised if she lied about
everything and just won in court >> So, unless you're a
cop, you can't use guns. Not just that you can't own guns. You
can't go to a gun range and use guns. You literally cannot control
a firearm. You cannot be you cannot have a firearm in your hands.
This order is effective until midnight on January 23rd, 2036.
What else do we got here? Man, the I don't know if I should grab
this guy's whole vod. The the Braxton guy, he just makes the
goofiest comments on this. I He should not have done this, man.
Man, it's rough. Why? This is what he said. I feel like every
single day I'm getting some >> This is uh this is Tee's
buddy. He's a really close friend of Tech. Okay. From the gotcha
community brain deadad idiot in my stream who says I defended
Teone. I don't think I've ever defended Tech. I'm friends with
him, but I don't think I've ever been like, "Oh, I'm going to
stick my neck out for that guy." Like, I don't think I've ever
had to defend him for anything. I just I'm just friends with
him, dog. Like, that's it.
But uh well, I'm I'm waiting till the uh the the court documents
come out to make my own official decision because I know Pink
and I know that Pink has a lot of uh mental health issues.
So, I would not be surprised if she lied about everything and
just won in court lying about
>> Dude, Dude, come on. I just I have no idea why he would
say this.
I actually don't know. I have no clue why he would say this.
It's like like
I I'm totally fine with by the way saying I'm friends with this
guy. Okay. I'm friends with this guy
and I don't want to comment. I want to wait until I see more.
I don't want to comment yet.
Like if if the documents are out, [__] send me to
them. I don't want to comment yet. That's all he should say,
right? Going any further into like, well, I I know this girl's
like really mentally ill. It's insane and it's just such a common
pattern on the internet, right? It's such a common pattern on
the internet to just do the mentally ill thing. It is like the
easiest thing. So many people fall into it, right? Oh, this girl,
she does Only Fans. She's like promiscuous and she also is mentally
ill. Well, is she really mentally ill? Do you know that? Well,
no, but I've heard stories. Okay, so you don't know. You're just
saying it. And even if you even if that were true, by the way,
let's say everything he thinks is true. Do you know that it's
relevant to this? Do you know that this is what happened? Or
are you just because you're friends with Techone trying to get
people to doubt the allegations against him? Right? Is that all
you're trying to That's what you're trying to do. Come on, man.
Be serious. You're just trying to cast out on the allegations.
And I believe this guy even said something along the lines of,
"Oh, I just didn't want Msk to be right." Bro, just wait until
we get to that. I don't know if I'm going to do a whole stream
yet, but there is another clip he has where he says something
like that. I'm like, "Dude,
stop deflecting to Msk. Shut the up about Msk." Okay,
Msk
is just reading stuff. Msk I I will say there's one place where
you could take his word, and that was um maybe on like the whiteboard
thing. Maybe on like some of those things. You'd have to take
his word if you wanted to. But broadly, you don't need Msk to
be involved to understand what's going on here.
And it's just crazy to me that people deflected to him. People
just keep deflecting to Misk's reputation. Like that is relevant
to anything going on with Pikachu. It's not at all.
It's not even a little bit. He's just mad Miz pulled Emmy and
Okay. I don't think so. But I don't think so. Let's just keep
looking. I would not be surprised if she lied about everything
and just won in court lying about everything. But
>> is that something you can do? Win in court lying about
everything?
I think you could get like an emergency TTRO,
but she had other evidence. There's other stuff going on here,
man. And that's all in documents that are out, by the way.
That's all in documents that are out.
Did you ever reach out to Axton to see if he go over the transcript?
Well, there is no transcript. Shut it down. He just has notes.
I could maybe I could maybe message the guy and ask him, "Hey,
could I get your notes?" But I'm guessing Miz wants those exclusively
for his stream because it's exclusive content, right?
Dude, it's so crazy to me that
man, I it just boils my blood when people do this. The first
reaction is just this guy. This This girl's crazy.
>> we'll see what happens. I'll make my own educated decision
from there.
Now,
I understand you guys don't want me to call this guy a and realistically.
We can see the figurines in the background. Okay,
I'm trying to be a little more calm,
especially because I know that he's already apologized. Okay,
given that he's already apologized, it feels and I read part
of that apology, it feels a little inappropriate to go as hard
on him as I would have if I'd just been watching this in real
time on a stream, you know? Sorry, I'm I'm getting affected by
the fact that I actually saw how this played out a little bit.
Why do we call him a Because he plays gota games. He loves stuff.
He's got a bunch of characters of I think um this is Ren, right,
from um Fates Day Night. I I
I haven't I've not watched any of this. I know that she's a popular
like anime character.
How old is she? She's definitely in high school. She's definitely
like 15 16 or something. So already right there, right? the Japanese
culture. Ren is 17. Not that crazy. Okay. Well, is she 17 later
on or is she 17 early on?
>> I actually don't know. >> That universe, by the
way, is like 15 years old. Okay. That universe is older than
she is. >> Uh unlike most of Twitter, I actually have a
functional brain and can make my own decisions based off of uh
based off of the information presented to me instead of someone's
clickbait bull title. Plus, if you're getting your news from
Miz, you're a idiot. Uh, but yeah,
anyways, mods, if you ever see someone like that, just ban them.
They're a waste of life. Uh,
by the way, this story would have been getting covered by me,
by a bunch of people like I'm associated with like Quean, Chud.
We would have all been covering this story from the second it
dropped because we would have all been aware of like Shimu, right?
Shimu is obviously somebody we talk to, somebody who's in our
community, somebody who is a himself like a big YouTuber or becoming
big. He I don't know how big he was before this. I hope he's
becoming big because he basically broke this Techone stuff and
made this call like months ago. Realistically, Shimu should be
massively benefiting from this,
Yeah. I I think this this call like him trying to go question
TeeOne and then getting Tee basically, you know, Tone saying
he can absolve himself. He is like absolving um
irrefutable evidence that he didn't do this and then he produces
nothing,
Um but I don't think I I don't think I leash at all, man. I I've
been trying to blow this guy up. Like this guy does the work.
He does the work, man.
He gets it
I'd never plagiarized from Shimu. Okay.
Unlike that Otter guy. Unlike that guy, I'd never plagiarize
from Shimu. We love Shimu here. All right.
Okay. All right.
Let's listen to >> And they should not, you know, be a
>> seen the techie tweet 16 minutes ago.
Did he tweet? What did he tweet? Okay, hold on, guys. Real quick,
let me correct some [__] I I see being said about
me. I wasn't convicted of a crime. I wasn't involved in criminal
proceeding. No, I'm not going to [__] jail or facing
any criminal punishment.
Yeah. Um well, luckily
Tone endorses my tweet. Let's go.
That's an endorsement OF MY TWEET. I DON'T SAY any of those things.
I've never said any of those things.
Let's go.
Um not only did he tweet, he is spam blocking accounts and hiding
replies. Oh,
you hidden replies.
Oh boy.
Uh, I probably can't just uh straight up look at this on stream
even. Jesus. Let me see if there's other replies here.
What is this? Oh, somebody linked the Henry Resilient video.
Okay. Okay.
We might do the Henry Resilient video a little bit later. We're
going to do our own version, but we might do it a little bit
later.
We'll start.
Jesus.
Oh, why did he he hid the um he hid the
he had this tweet. Who's your favorite and least favorite gotcha
content creator and why? I'll go first. Favorite Lucari. He's
like me but black.
He I can't believe he went out of his way to hide this one,
right? I can't believe that he went out of his way to hide this
one.
This one ain't even bad.
Well, sorry. It's It looks really bad, but like it has nothing
to do with this. It doesn't paint him as a rapist. That tells
me that he is rattled beyond belief. Okay, he's doing that [__]
Techon do be blocking a lot of people on Twitter. I can't really
complain. I block a lot of people on Twitter. You if you respond
to one of my tweets that has like a point and it's just something
irrelevant to my tweet, I block you immediately.
You like have a legitimate concern or something or you Yeah,
it's I just block, man.
If people want to criticize like the tweet though, I engage.
Don't block for that. Can't block for that, man. You got to engage.
Okay.
Wow.
What a guy. What a guy. This techone guy.
Let's see. So, I did none of these things. Fantastic. You love
to see it.
Oh. Uhoh.
That's my
That's my screenshot. You know how I know that's my screenshot?
Because when you look at this document,
um this is how I should have watermarked this. I SHOULD HAVE
WATERMARKED IT. I'm stupid. But um I actually I did the editing
on this to put it together to like compose this. This there's
a split. There's a page split here. Right. Right here. It's stalking
section. There's like a page split.
I did this. I made this.
I made this. When a streamer like I like blocks me, I cry. Simple
as. Wow. If you watermarked it, they might not have used it.
No, they would have used it. It perfectly conveys the information.
Perfectly conveys the information. So, they would have used it
for sure. Nobody cares tone. Oh boy.
So, this is the thing. I don't know. I can't say to 100% certainty.
Okay.
I do know that this would be exactly like when people called
Trump a rape. Uh, right. Trump was held liable for insulting
I think Eene Carol, right? And people called him a rape. people
were calling him a racist all the time.
I don't know if that like I don't know if he sued anybody. I
don't know how
saw that,
but that is the comparable here is basically
he was found civily liable for these things, civily likely to
have committed these things. And that's not a criminal conviction.
It is different.
Didn't Trump sue ABC or some? I have no idea if he sued them
over that. Maybe he did sue them over that. That's what I'm saying
is basically that would give us the comparable to know whether
or not you could say this guy's a or not without getting sued.
That's the comparable something. Hold on. Let me uh let me go
see and quote my own tweets. Hold on. Dead.
Hold on. Dead.
We got a new tweet.
Wait here. There it is. My tweet does none of these things. So,
it seems fair to say it has the techone seal of approval.
Let's go. I'm very precise in the things I say here.
Very, very precise. Okay, we're not we're not making mistakes.
We're not looking to get sued.
We're not looking to get sued. Okay, we
being calm, being collect. Okay, I'll lost that post. I'll like
that post. It's one of your best. Okay. Wow. Detect's friend
flip on him. We are going to cover that. Watching you back. Don't
worry. We're just We're chilling. We're waiting a second for
people to finish up, you know, roll in. Giving people probably
till about 40 minutes on the stream and then we'll start reading
the documents. All right. Wait, what?
Somebody Wait, what is this question in Twitch chat? Did I miss
this earlier? Hold on. If you weren't with someone sensually,
why would she have gotten so close to him to put herself in a
situation as such?
What a question.
Um,
that is truly truly my brain is wrinkling at the that question.
I don't I don't know how to take it
here. I'll let you guys watch the rest of the Braxton >> allowed
to be in the stream. >> I'll find it.
>> He mentioned his audio levels.
I feel >> I do not know how to think for myself.
>> It's okay. Don't worry. I will tell you how to think
so you don't have to think
>> Thinking critically is hard. I get it. I understand
why nobody would want to do it. The the thing is so I actually
called um >> I called Zachi the other day >> and
he can't talk about what happened in it. Um
so I didn't really get much information out. Um but he told me
basically make my own decision on it. So that's what I'm going
to do. I'm going to and that's honestly that's what I was going
to do anyways. But, you know, it's nice that he's he's like,
you know, just you make your own decision on it because then
that means that he trusts in full that he did nothing wrong,
right? >> And I think that that says a lot. >> Just
knows how to manipulate. >> I'm going to be making my own
decision on it when the documents are out, but I don't think
the documents are actually out yet for the court case. So, everything
that we're hearing online is word of mouth of someone that has
a vendetta against Teo.
>> So, that's not Well, hold on. If you wanted to say the
funny thing here, okay, to me, the very funny thing to me
yeah, hold on, Creger. It's it's um trust me, he he eventually
realizes the funny thing here is everything this guy said could
actually he could still maintain this position like where he's
where he's getting it wrong or he's just a total he's the exact
reason he's complaining about because essentially he could say
one of two things. I want to wait until I see what evidence there
was that this really happened, right?
Or he could say
like based on allegations alone, I'm going to believe the the
victim and like allegations and the ruling of the court, which
were both out when Miskf was talking about this. I'm going to
side with her.
But what he did was he went, "Well, I'm not going to look at
any of that. I'm going to like ignore Msk is talking about that
stuff. I don't want to Msk." And then he said he's going to wait.
But all the information was out to make his
There are no transcripts. I don't even know if there will be
transcripts, Chucker Joe. We'll see. Um, there are no transcripts
out yet, but they did file the official protective order today.
We're about to go over it.
So, I have learned the hard you Oh, man. I'm going to I'm going
to say it, man. So, let me tell you what why these
are so hot, but in practicality, they are the worst thing to
ever exist. So lip fillers, they do make your lips look as.
But the problem is anybody who has lip fillers cannot suck a
dick worth a damn.
It sucks. It sucks
dark given what you now know, right? That this is after after
this was filed. This is a month after this is filed,
And he's talking about this and like it's I it seems like it's
obvious who he's referring to >> cuz if they suck too hard
it'll up their lip fillers.
It's just not worth it. It's really not. It's so lame. It's so
lame, bro. It's so lame. So that's why I stopped giving a about
the fake lip look. It's just It's just There's no point, man.
That's >> I think we can all say yuck, right? Gross. Gross,
man. [__] Gross, dude. Gross, man.
Yeah, there's the lip fillers are a thing. Yeah. Yeah. They take
silicone and they inject it into your lips to give it those plump
look. Um and then it stays in your lips to look really good in
about 2 months and then it just sits there and just kind of dissipates.
Uh but it it always remains in your lips, but eventually you're
going to have to get it removed in like 5 10 years. Uh but yeah,
the videos about the cat. Yeah. Well, oh yeah, >> good
one. Okay, so gross. Gross. That's basically all that to say,
yuck, yuck, gross, yuck, gross.
Okay, so that was the allegation and this sort of lays out that
hey, I do believe it ruined her lip fillers and it's just >> lame,
bro. It's so lame. So that's why I stopped giving a about the
fake lip. >> Hold on. >> It sucks. It sucks cuz if
they suck too hard, it'll [__] up their lip fillers.
>> so again, the allegation is he she just gotten the lip
filler done and she didn't want to because her lips hurt and
then the filler migrated around
because of the incident. All right. And I believe as a part of
this and we we haven't gone over the documents. I didn't go redact
all those documents. I just let you know we just rolled with
the miz coverage of it. But I believe the allegation later or
or what they pro had for evidence in court, I believe, would
be that she went to a plastic surgeon to talk about this and
got it addressed. Okay. How is he even going to be able to make
a response to this without violating the order? Well, Trucker
Joe, I don't know if you missed it, but he did actually already
respond. Not really to this, but he responded kind of in a general
way that
nobody truly knows about. You know what I'm saying? Like, like,
sorry. He responded a genu general way that nobody was doing.
Like nobody was doing the things he pointed out. Okay. He says,
"Guys, real quick, let me correct some I see being said about
me. I wasn't convicted of a crime." We didn't say that. I wasn't
involved in a criminal proceeding. We didn't say that. No, I'm
not going to jail or facing any criminal punishment. We didn't
say that. Right, guys? This was a civil hearing with a significantly
lower standard of proof than a criminal proceeding.
It's preponderance of evidence and I've explained this to people,
right?
Give me a bit. I got to finish a couple more things up and we'll
talk after. Appreciate y'all. So, I think he'll be able to say
what it wasn't. He'll be able to speak around the edges and say
things he hasn't been convicted of. Right. Yeah. So, again, I've
never implied he was criminally convicted. I just said what the
court found. And by the way, this would be like one judge. This
wouldn't be a jury. This would be like one judge looking over
these documents. Oh, I also forgot to say in the legal mindset
stuff from yesterday, he says it's a jury trial, and I didn't
point that out. It's totally It's not a jury trial at all. He
got a lot of things wrong in his coverage. His coverage was pretty
rough, to be honest with you.
Uh, his coverage was very rough. It just was doxing a lot, so
it's like almost impossible for me to cover if I don't if I don't
want to like just let him throw out addresses and and everything
that it's actually tough for me to cover. Judge presiding is
a fair man. We love Judge Presiding, don't we? We love him. He's
awesome. He's the best. By the way, Frame's sister was in Misk's
chat yesterday. 6 hours 35 minutes into the VOD. Oh,
really?
Uh, wait. What was her username? Just give me your username.
We'll pull up the chat
Yellow fever patient zero. Welcome to the stream. Very, very
crazy name. Do you want to go ahead and throw me the chat me
the the name she used in chat and then I could just look up her
looks?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. This is what we're looking for. All right.
So, what the [__] Oh, hold on. Wait. Are you sure
this is who this was? Like, she was just straight up like, you
know, she was just cheering on gambling.
Okay. Very crazy. Very crazy. She loves the gamba. Uh, okay.
Okay. Bar bar. Let's go. Let's go.
Did the same thing to me when I was 12 or so. Switch to this.
I don't even know what this is. Okay. Hold on. >> Nervous
to write all this and I still am. But it means a lot to see someone
with your platform call it out. I'm F's sister. As she calls
me online, her little sister. I've known about him since I was
seven or eight. When Freeman has started dating, a lot happened
with him and he had a big impact on my childhood and my family.
Seeing someone who can actually make a difference acknowledge
it helps me more than I can really explain.
Is this confirmed to be his sis her
>> How do we confirm this?
confirm. I can I can prove it, but I'm free. She say I can't
prove it. She mean I can't prove it. Oh, I see. Oh, wow. There's
a whole bunch of stuff here. That is >> Can you DM me?
>> I Without being able to without being able to prove
who that is, it feels like um I'm probably not going to cover
too much of this. Okay, that without being able to prove who
it is, I I feel like whatever. I don't I don't know, man. If
it gets proven out who it is, if she does prove who it is.
Okay, hold on. We'll see. Does he get >> Jenny Pig, if
you're homeless, you could stay over. I'm sorry. I could prove
it, but I'm from your sister. >> Serif, we'll we'll cover
this later tonight. Okay, that's a later topic. >> Yeah,
Jenny, come over topic. That's a later topic. >> Wait,
she is.
>> Oh, god.
Okay, real quick.
Okay,
so this is the the protective order such that it is. We got Mr.
John Roberts here. Okay,
got the defendants. So, we have got this section here. All right,
it just it lays out some basic information off the bat. And then
we've got this section here,
findings and orders. Okay, after considering the application,
evidence, and arguments of the parties, if any, the courts,
and then it goes through all of the possible findings that would
lead to a protected order. Okay, for this one, they choose F.
the court. So, we'll read this again. Actually, hold on. I should
pull my tweet really quick cuz I put this together in a much
better way. Okay. So, after consideration, considering the application
evidence and arguments of the parties, if any, the court finds
that there are reasonable grounds to believe the respondent committed
one or more of the following offenses against the applicant.
And then it has a bunch of checkboxes: trafficking of persons,
continuous trafficking of persons, continuous abuse of a young
child or disabled individual, indecency. These are all things
that are left blank. They're not the things Tech did. indecency
with a child. Uh the fi the first text we get is assault section
penal code. Then so that's the first one. So sex assault
uh indecent assault is left blank. Aggravated assault is left
blank and stalking. So stalking here is section 40 42.072
penal code. So suffice to say when you get through all of these
things, all right, all of these and it finally at the end it
says therefore the court grants the application and issues the
pro this protective order against the
So they've determined through the civil
that there are reasonable grounds to believe that Tetone committed
assault. He insulted Pinky Chu and he stalked Pinky Chu. Okay,
that is what I believe the contempor contemporaneous evidence
she has is. I I believe that was the contemporaneous evidence
presented in the trial. They filed for her plastic surgeon to
be somebody who testified remotely.
Okay.
Um that is something that happened for the trial. And I'm guessing
that he said yes, this is this is you know I I had to replace
these lip fillers or something. I don't know if she So, we'd
have to wait for the transcript to find out if she basically
uh if she told him more like what happened or if she gave any
details. That would be even worse for Tetoone if she gave details
back then when they were still together. I'm guessing it was
she just went back and said like I was having my boyfriend and
this happened and blah blah blah blah blah. But the contemporaneous
issue of like hey this
that was enough to push the court over the top along with some
other things, right? We remember back te lied about some of the
stuff like he he just he was online and he was lying a lot. I
do believe that his online coverage of this
statement would have led to $3. Who's the pink person?
>> Who's Pikachu? Uh not appropriate while we're doing
this stuff just yet. Ruben Ruben. Okay, I'm going to leave that
one out. Thank you so much.
Oh, you know what? It even if it's not appropriate. If you guys
don't know who Pikachu is, this is Pikachu. Okay, this is Pinky
>> Okay, that's who Pikachu is.
The guy didn't know who Pikachu was. He was wondering who it
was. I had to show him. Okay. Can't have people just going through
this and not knowing anything.
You know, that would be that would be absurd. All right. That
would frankly that would be absurd.
Uh, hold on. I should just I didn't even double check this, but
okay. I Yeah, I didn't double check the I was like, "Oh, I didn't
actually double check this document." Somebody else did, but
Okay. So, we're going through that was the binding of the court.
Okay. So, that's that's the biggest thing that makes up the tweet.
That is the biggest element.
All right. So relationships to the parties current and former
or former dating partners
current of former or former dating partners are or were members
of the same family or household. So they lived together and they
were dating partners. Okay. Conditions and terms of the order.
So this is a big one. All right. These are all the outcomes.
These are all the things that these are outcomes of the protective
order being filed. So they can basically customize this to say
you can't do certain things. I'm assuming some of these are like
autofilled out like auto yes unless there's a reason not to,
but it's still cool to know exactly like what was all put in
here. I didn't include all of this in the tweet because some
of it's like pretty obvious or you know redundant in some ways.
Give me a second. Okay, so conditions and terms of the order.
Mark all that apply. The court finds that the following conditions
and terms are necessary or appropriate to prevent or reduce the
likelihood of family violence, violence, or future harm to a
person protected by this order or a member of the family or household
of a person protected by this order.
The court orders the respondent to obey all entries marked below.
The respondent must not commit further acts of family violence
against applicant or any member of the applicant's family or
household, including acts intended to result in physical harm,
bodily injuries, assault, or assault or threats reasonably placing
a person in fear of physical harm, bodily injury, assault, or
sexual assault.
Not they they must not communicate in any manner with a person
protected by this order or a member of the family or household
of a person protected by this order except through a protected
person's attorney or a person appointed by the court. The name
of the attorney or or person appointed by the court is this is
her lawyer. The court finds that good cause exists to prohibit
direct communication from the respondent. So he cannot communicate
directly to Pinky Chu either. Okay, the first one's pretty obvious.
Second one, I mean I I think it's also pretty obvious given the
protected order was granted, but it is
Okay. You must not communicate in a threatening or harassing
manner directly or indirectly with a person protected by this
order. That's Pinky Chu. Or a member of the family or household
of a person protected by this order. Now, this will be interesting
because I don't know how far the line goes out here with like
his titles and stuff. If you remember, we looked at the titles
yesterday of some of his streams. Those were pretty spooky. Some
of the commentary he explicitly directed at Pinky was pretty
spooky, pretty weird.
Um, yeah. So, I guess, yeah, you can't communicate in a threatening
or harassing manner. I This seems pretty subjective. I don't
know exactly what that means. Okay. Tone must not
communicate a threat through any person to a person protected
by this order or a member of the household or family.
He must not go within 200 yards of a person protected by this
order or a member of the family or household of a person protected
by this order except as authorized by this order. So or the family
or household of a person protected by this order. So can't go
to her house, can't go near her family and can't go near her.
Okay. And he cannot go within 200 yards of the residence or place
of employment/ business of a person protected by this order.
Pinky or any of her family members businesses or something uh
where they work the addresses the oh the address of the prohibited
locations are and then confidential by order of the court. So
the court actually doesn't say where these addresses would be.
Okay.
Teto must not go within 200 yards of a child care facility or
school of a person protected by this order or a member of the
family or household. So while this was funny I almost included
this. This is basically just the same thing as before, right?
It's basically saying don't go somewhere where they're required
to be.
Now, as funny as it is that he can't go near a a child care facility
or school, it's just it's just to say that's not an excuse. This
is more meant for this is more meant for like if you had kids
with the person, you can't go near the school. If you like there's
a whole bunch of different things that this would apply for.
It's mostly for family violence, right? It's not actually saying
we found him to be a danger to children or something. As funny
as that would be. Okay. As funny as that would be to say that.
It's not actually saying that. Okay. So, I didn't I tried to
keep the tweet, you know, impartial.
Teto must not engage in conduct that is reasonably likely to
harass, annoy, alarm, abuse, torment, or embarrass when that
conduct is directed specifically toward a person protected by
this order or a member of the household family, including not
following or causing another to follow a protected person. Now,
this one is tricky. Okay, this one I think is the one where like
him seething on the internet, him seething on his stream could
almost certainly if he's talking about the lawsuit talking about
Pinky or you know people who [__] him over. This
one could get dicey on stream cuz this seems pretty subjective.
I don't know. I don't know, man.
This is like pretty rough. I think I'm guessing you'd have to
be pretty sure it's directed at her, right?
Yeah. He can't direct his viewers or anybody else to harass her
either. Yes.
So, that one seems very broad in a way, like possibly very broad.
And I'm not sure how a live streamer prevents that kind of somebody
who live streams like hours and hours a day. That seems actually
like
for techone specifically.
I feel like he his content is very often making himself the victim
and talking about people who have persecuted him. I don't know
how he does his normal content where he gets to be the victim
and doesn't eventually go into his primary source of victimization
in his mind, which is this, right? I actually don't know if he's
if he's capable of avoiding it. It is just like what he wants
to do all the time. Okay. He's as bad as Miz, if not worse, when
it comes to looping on his own perceived victimhood. I think
he's worse than Miz, actually. I do think he's worse than Miz.
I think Miz
Teone, when he was supposed to not talk about this, he went on
stream and talked about it, right? when he when he was basically
being told by his lawyers very likely that hey don't go talk
about this at all he still went online and talked about it
Miz when he was like when things were in like a cold war I do
think he avoided talking about Emiru like a lot
I think seemed like he was capable
okay let's continue on TTO must not take harm threaten or interfere
with the care custody or control of the following pet companion
animal so I don't even know if this is actually included
I I don't know if they had a pet together. He must not transfer,
encumber, or otherwise dispose of property mutually owned or
leased by the parties except when done so in the ordinary course
of business. That must not track or monitor the personal property
or a motor vehic motor vehicle in the possession of a person
protected by this order without the person's effective consent,
including by not tracking or monitoring the person with a tracking
device or application or by physically following the person.
Teto must not own, possess, buy, or attempt to buy, receive,
or attempt to receive, or in any other way obtain possession,
ownership, or control of a firearm, firearm parts, or ammunition
unless the respondent is a peace officer actively engaged in
employment as a sworn full-time paid employee of the state of
a state agency or political subdivision. So, unless you're a
cop, you can't use guns. Not just that, you can't own guns. You
can't go to a gun range and use guns. You literally cannot control
a firearm. You cannot be you cannot have a firearm in your hands,
right? It's not that you can't own a firearm. It's that you cannot
ever use a firearm. And this goes for 10 years, by the way.
Um, TeeOne actually like out of the gun tuber community. Unlucky.
Technone joins ICE when I don't think that's happening, man.
I don't I'll be real. I don't think that's happening.
Teto must not attempt to prevent or dissuade a protected person
from attending a hearing, testifying, or making a report to any
law enforcement agency or another person.
All right. So then we just go through. Now there are additional
terms added to this and we can actually go down to those right
now. Okay. So there are other conditions or terms. See exhibit
A for additional ter conditions and terms of this order.
Now A is interesting because this this is something they had
to custom they had to custom brew these. Okay,
which leads me to believe that evidence was presented that led
the court to believe that this was a concern. Okay, these are
not things that are traditionally included on the form and they
were added to the form as an as a special exhibit so that they
could say don't do these things. Okay,
they can do that without a gun crime occurring. They absolutely
can. Chapid 81 Supreme Court decision in 2024 says if you have
an active uh restraining order, an active civil restraining order,
you cannot own guns. It is constitutionally okay to take the
guns from somebody with an active restraining order given a uh
like a in a domestic violence situation.
That's uh decided.
So boom.
Not even not even up for debate.
Uh, Teto must not communicate in any manner with a person protected
by this order or in any manner whatsoever
uh in oh sorry protected by this order in any manner whatsoever
including through phone calls, emails, text messages, any kind
of social media or in any kind of communication through third
parties. Now
that one seems to almost even more broadly say
you cannot talk about this person. I So does that would Twitter
count as a third party here or social media, right? If he goes
on social media and he starts whining about the case, he starts
complaining about the things that have happened, is that going
to be like counted as sending a message to her? Cuz obviously
he could direct it enough to be sent to her. I don't know. The
the answer there is I don't know. I'm thinking about it. I have
no idea.
So,
relinquish any firearms in the respondent's possession in Techton's
possession by Monday, February 2nd, 2026 to law enforcement and
provide a receipt of relinquishment. The Michelle Lock, this
is the attorney, no later than 5:00 p.m. on January 26th, 2026.
He probably got lucky on this that or he probably didn't have
to do this right away or I think he did though cuz they had a
bunch of stuff closed down. If respondent does not possess or
own any firearms as testified by respondent, then respondent
shall provide a sworn affidavit indicating such to Michelle L.
Lockach by Monday, February 2nd, 2026. Now, he does provide this
this affidavit. I do wonder if he could just give his firearms
away.
Okay. Finally, the last thing. Teone must notate,
reproduce, or share any kind of photographic video or electronic
or digital media that is a recording of the applicant or displays
an image of the applicant. He literally can't even I believe
this would say you can't even quote tweet her. Like if she's
got a picture, you couldn't even like quote tweet the picture,
right? You're actually done, son. You don't get to do that. All
right.
You ain't get to do that.
I do believe that he cannot post send to anybody for any reason
any picture of her. Okay.
Now, this if we're to believe Miskefe, which I I do on this one,
right, the Msk and Axiom transcript, this is likely because they
had reason to believe that he had threatened to send revenge
to somebody to publish it or to send it. And I think this is
what this custom order comes from. Like, hey, if you ever think
about sending anything, I don't even care. You might think it's
on the line. It's not on the line. You can't send any picture
of this, okay? You can't send a single picture of Pikachu. Not
even a little bit. Okay? Nothing. nothing.
You can't do because we don't trust you, Teeone. We don't trust
you. You made the threat. We don't trust you anymore. That sort
of lends a lot of credence to the idea that Teone had himself
made some kind of threat that made them add this special case
here saying, "You can't even have pictures of this person. Don't
even Don't even try to share pictures of this person, okay? Don't
do it. Don't do it." OH,
WHAT? REAPING RUBEN WITH THE INSANE TECH. If you ever want to
not be reacted to by Techone, all you've got to do is find your
nearest
your nearest picture of Pikachu
and you've got Tech.
>> Let's [__] go.
>> Jo can no longer react.
>> I guess you can get the clip editing. We're not okay.
Live reacting. No shot.
Sorry, I I also, as I was going to play that, I knocked over
a drink, so I knocked my water over. We're back to the >> bro.
I feel like every single day I'm getting some brain deadad idiot
in my stream who says I defended Techone. I don't think I've
ever defended Techone once in my life.
I'm friends with him, but I don't think I've ever been like,
"Oh, I'm going to stick my neck out for that guy." Like I don't
think I've ever had to defend him
for anything. >> I've I've never defended Teone ever. I've
never defended Why would you think I defended Teeone? Why would
you think I'd defend Techone? I'd never defend Teone on anything,
man. I'd never I'd never do something like defend Techone. Oh,
Pinkie Chu. That That [__] is mentally ill. That
[__] is totally She's like a mentally ill
She's like a mentally ill She's like totally mentally ill, guys.
She's like She's like totally mentally ill. Hold
decision because I know Pink and I know that Pink has a lot of
uh mental health
>> What the >> I would not be surprised if she lied
about everything and just won in court lying about everything.
But we'll see what happens. I'll make Bro, seriously,
what I This is the dumbest statement. Okay. Now, again, I do
believe he's apologized. I will go over his statement. I'll go
over the rest of his clips from his stream as well. All right.
But yeah, we will go over it. All right.
There's no way he thinks that's how court works. Well,
listen. Maybe she just lied. Maybe she just lied the whole time.
Maybe she just lied about literally everything, guys.
People with mental ill issues can't be assaulted/abused apparently.
Yeah.
It's like or that they would lie about their like I think
that's it's just a massive problem, right? to just presume that
somebody's lying because they have some
thing going on.
By the way, just to be clear,
just to be clear, this guy must know for a fact that Teton is
an unmedicated diagnosed schizophrenic.
Okay, so to me, just anybody who goes in or talks about Pinky
Choose mental issues without mentioning that Tecton is an unmedicated,
diagnosed schizophrenic,
you are bad faith. You are trying to sweep for this guy. Obviously.
So, all right.
You can't just go, "Oh, one person here has mental illness."
No. Tone has unmedicated
diagnosed schizophrenia. Okay.
Is that confirmed? He has said he's diagnosed. So, have I checked?
Do I have his medical records? No. He has said he's diagnosed.
He has said he doesn't take his med his medication. And so, I
just I man, no sympathy, dog. No sympathy for these. Okay. Zero
zero sympathy.
It's crazy.
All right.
Okay. I haven't even finished this whole clip yet. We should
uh maybe we finish this whole clip right now and then we'll go
back to reading the documents and then we'll do his reaction
after the documents and a couple other reactions from around
the whole sphere. Okay.
Did trigger his skits, brother? I don't think so. my own educated
decision from
>> because uh >> so he'll make his own educated.
>> So I would not be surprised if she lied about everything
and just won in court lying about everything. But we'll see what
happens. I'll make my own educated decision from there.
>> Sounds like your educated decision is going a really
weird direction, buddy. Because uh unlike most of Twitter, I
actually have a functional brain and can make my own decisions
based off of uh oh my god, the smash cut clips of this guy going
through the five stages. Okay, the entire Kubler Ross model.
Okay, the five stages of dying live on his stream. Okay, we're
gonna watch him go through every stage. Denial, anger, bargaining,
depression, acceptance. Okay. He's going to go through the whole
thing in the next like hour after that comment when everybody
like this first gets clipped and he realizes and he looks into
it and he's like, "Oh, wow. This is really bad.
This is really bad, guys.
Sometimes people should just shut up. Brother, you play gotcha.
Why did you even comment? Why did you even get baited into commenting?
Just shut the up based off of the information presented to me
instead of someone's clickbait title. Plus, if you're getting
your news from Miz, you're a idiot." And that's exactly what
it was, right? That's exactly what it was. This guy hated Miskf
so much. He was going to denigrate somebody for I what he said
was their mental problems, right? He's going to do that. He's
going to denigrate the victim in this story because he hates
Msk. I hate Msk. I just randomly with random women. Okay. I randomly
with victims of my friends assaults my assaulting friends. My
I'm still not totally sure on the on the rapist part. Okay. But
yes, his friend assault, he he totally stands by it, right? He's
like He's like, "Yeah, I'm gonna I'm gonna totally denigrate
the victim here because he hates mischief." Embarrassing, man.
It's just sad. [__] goof. >> Uh I don't know.
>> But yeah.
>> Anyways, mods, if you ever see someone >> name
is rapetone,
his name is Rape Tone. Okay. It really is. I'm sorry. It really
is. Said there was no reason to believe this. It was totally
false. It was totally fabricated. RIGHT. THAT was the standard
technone set right off the bat. This is totally fabricated. This
is totally fabricated. It's totally made up. It's totally invented.
And now we come to see, well, a court certainly believed it.
You cannot possibly You cannot possibly make me believe that
a court would say you can't have weapons for 10 years if it was
completely fabricated. Okay, that's my bar. If this allegation
were fabricated,
there is no chance a judge in Texas would say you don't get to
own guns for 10 years. That is complete. So, while we don't have
the transcript specifically to know exactly how, you know, the
witness testimony and stuff went, I'm that's my bar, man. That's
where I'm going. That's that's how I'm, you know, picking a northstar
on what to believe about this situation >> like that. Just
ban them. They're a waste of life. Uh, and they should not, you
know, be allowed to be in the
>> Please, Mr. Streamer. I do not know how to think for
myself.
It's okay. Don't worry. I will tell you how to think so you don't
have to think
Thinking critically is hard. I get it. >> I understand
why nobody would want to do >> The The thing is, so I actually
called
>> I called Taki the other day >> and he can't talk
about what happened in it. Um
so I didn't really get much information out. Um but he told me
basically make my own decision on it. So that's what I'm going
to do. I'm going to and that's honestly that's what I was going
to do anyways. But, you know, it's nice that he's he's like,
you know, just you make your own decision on it because then
that means that he trusts in full that he did nothing wrong,
right? And I think that that says a lot. I'm going to be making
my own decision on it when the documents are out, but I don't
think the documents are actually out yet for the court case.
So, everything that we're hearing online is word of mouth of
someone that has a vendetta against Teo,
like everyone else on the internet,
And I'm not a fake piece of who just throws my friends away the
second that they get caught up in something
I'm not like I'm not like Atsu or um the fake people that run
in the crowds of the gotcha space or the top streamers. I'm not
going to >> Dude. Okay, man. Okay, so couple things there.
I had to walk away for a second, so I didn't I didn't respond
to all of that. Hold on. Couple things there.
Teone telling you to make your own decision does not mean he
knows he's innocent. That's not what that means at all. Right.
Am I crazy? I That's him covering his ass.
Or possibly even saying like, "Well, I listen. I'm not going
to sweep for myself here. You just make your own decision." It's
It's one of the two. It's not him saying he's innocent. It's
him saying I can't talk about this. Literally, I believe that
if Tekone had logs of him discussing this situation with somebody
that could feasibly be used to say like especially with this
guy who's going to come out and say, "Well, Pinkiey's mentally
has mental issues or something." Like if I'm if if Pinky wants
to actually look like run this down,
I think they should ask for the communications Braxton guy and
see who told him when that Pinky has mental issues. Who told
you that? Because if it was Tekone recently and he's telling
you and you go on your live stream and talk about her mental
issues, that's a violation of the protective order, that is encouraging
somebody else to make statements that would, you know, uh, like
annoy, abuse, humiliate, whatever her, right? He's not supposed
to be talking about this to anybody.
Um, now, could he talk to somebody in private? He could talk
to somebody in private, but I do believe that if he's talking
to somebody about it who's going to stream,
I think he can't have an opinion. In fact, shockingly,
man, hold on. What am I thinking here?
Oh, I feel like this happened in another case. I'm not going
to pull it up right now. Hold on. Uh, Twisted Rope. >> Always
throw pennies. >> Always throw penny. True. Always be throwing
pennies. Throw kicks. Throw kicks on the kick platform, guys.
We really appreciate the kicks. Thank you so much, Twisted Rope.
Uh, the Nicholas Light dude is already tweeting saying, "These
courts are rigged." No shot. No shot. No shot cuz I've seen some
people say that. Right.
Hold on. X
N N N N N N N N Light TV. I don't know what his what his ex handle
is. Go ahead and send me any like any posts on stuff like that.
I'll try to find it here. Nicholas Light. Let's pull it up. What
did he say? What did this guy say?
I'M BLOCKED BEFORE. I' I'VE NEVER TWEETED AT THIS GUY BEFORE.
How am I
I've never tweeted at this bro before. What the?
I'm preemptively blocked.
That's man. That is what is this? January 28th. Okay, hold on.
Response to techone.
These on Twitter, especially Braxophone, believing all the lies
being said about you. All because of politics. They refuse to
listen to the facts. They don't even understand what a civil
hearing is. They truly believe you're a convicted criminal. Well,
hold on. I that might be my take on the Brax guy. The Bratz guy
might be enough of a reason that he opened his mouth on this.
He got like push back because of the how stupid he was with the
way he spoke. He might have like actually meant to be staying
with Teone. Like I think I think the the tech the Bra guy
if his standard of evidence was like beyond a reasonable doubt
or it's my friend, I'm going to stick with them. Which I I kind
of feel like that's what he was laying out a little bit. I think
he just really didn't understand what he was looking at
people just didn't know.
I I truly believe that people He just doesn't know like what
he's reading. I think if he really did understand, it's possible
he would have stood with Teone, but he got like too much push
back and he just folded anyway.
By the way, I if you want to say even if this guy's found, you
know, civily liable for assault, I'm going to stand by him. That's
like whatever. Okay. I wouldn't do that on your platform, but
if you if you just want to not comment, that's fine. What the
problem I had with this Braxophone guy is that he is spreading
the same thing a bunch of other people are about like Pinky Chu
being mentally ill when like that's just complete. One because
of Taton's own mental illnesses. Like there's no reason to say
it's only affecting one of them. Two because the court took her
side. Like three because it's just a place to start with the
allegation. Like she was she's alleging she was victimized. And
you immediately follow up with oh yeah she's mentally ill though.
Like you understand that this is why people target people with
mental illness for abuse. because nobody will believe them. Like
you are perpetuating something awful by by even providing that
opinion to the internet. Anyway,
sorry we didn't finish the tweet. They didn't even understand
what a civil hearing is. They truly believe you're a convicted
criminal, lol. Any woman could do this to a man. No proof needed.
And all the feminist NPCs online will believe it all and falsely
accuse men of these crimes because it fits their agenda. They
don't care about the truth. Ah, this is not true though. This
is where this guy [__] up really badly. Okay.
And he's lucky I guess block me. I can't I literally can't talk
back cuz all I would say here is do you really believe they took
this guy's guns for 10 years with no proof with no evidence of
anything? Like they didn't even see evidence that this guy was
a threat to her. They just did it for funsies. They were like
oh well we just believe women. Tone was like hey do you have
any proof of this? And she was like no I don't have any proof.
This guy me though. And the judge was like yes we believe the
women now. We believe the me too happened and we believe the
women
evidence. What is evidence?
That that didn't happen. That's literally not what happened.
It's it's insane coke to think that your country would function
that way ever. Like it's it's insane.
Woke Texas judges. Yeah, exactly. Uh I think Oh, maybe maybe
I think he himself thinks he's guilty of whatever charge. Like
otherwise he would be insisting he's innocent and not like make
your own uh not like make up your own mind. Sure. Yeah, it could
be. And so logic from 2016 a little bit.
Any any man believing all this garbage online, this could happen
to you. Oh, and Miskf
like I I'm going to be as you know as good faith as like steel
manning as I could possibly be. Okay,
there is a chance you could get the temporary TTRO, the temporary,
sorry, protective order.
There's a chance you could get that on very little evidence,
just your word. You would say, "Hey, this guy assaulted me and
here's the times it happened and I want a protective order."
There's a chance that they would be pretty lenient about giving
you that without like hard proof of any kind.
I do not believe that same thing applies to a permanent
10-year protective order. Okay. That do you think judges in Texas
are unaware? They can't be unaware. We're reading the protective
order. It says very very very explicitly in here multiple times
everything about gun ownership. Do you think Texans don't understand
the importance of the Second Amendment? Of course they do. Right.
They they are weighing evidence here. They know they're taking
away your Second Amendment right for 10 years. They will not
do that with no evidence. The idea that they just do that on
her word is insane.
It's obviously insane. Okay. All right. We're back to reading
the document now and we read Nicholas Light being a total found
out he blocked me preemptively. Son of a [__] Son
of a
>> Ride or die with a stalker. >> You know they got
your man. They got your mans on assault charges. >> Yeah.
The [__] be hanging with the you be hanging with
>> Oh sex. >> Dude, I'm I'm sorry. This Asian guy
is so unrelated. how he like turns and he just turns and smiles
at the camera here. He like he's totally cheesing at the camera.
It's so funny when he like looks here. He like looks over at
the camera. He's looking at it, too.
and he was your man. He was your boy.
>> You grew up with him.
>> You ain't know what he was doing. You ain't feel bad
at all. Like no guilt. Hey, you know,
>> go
let's go.
Very funny.
Okay, back to the document. We're reading. We're reading. Orders
regarding separation of wireless telephone service account. I
don't think this applies. Costs. The court orders the respondant
to pay six the $16 protective order fee. The standard fees charged
by the clerk of the court in a general civil proceeding for the
cost of serving this order. the cost of the court and all the
fees, charges, and expenses incurred in connection with the application
of and this order.
And there's one more thing. The court orders the respondent to
pay attorney's fees in the amount of $15,000. The court must
consider the respondent's income and ability to pay for before
assessing attorney's fees. There's a section of the law that
see exhibit B for additional conditions and terms regarding attorney's
fees.
They give them like a whole payment structure actually to tell
you the truth. like like you basically get interest in. I'm I'm
guessing 15K ain't nothing for techone. Okay, I'm guessing 15K
is like light light work. Okay, lightweight. It's nothing.
Anyway, seven additional/ special orders. None are entered. The
court enters the following additional or special orders. Ctt
attached statewide law enforcement information system and stalking
protective order. C attached exhibit A for additional conditions
and terms of this order. see exhibit B for additional conditions
and terms regarding attorney's fees. Okay. And then there's warnings.
It's like $500 or six months in jail for violating. And then
if you I think we saw if you've stalked multiple times or if
you what violate in terms of stalking. I think there's a longer
one. Uh a violation of this order by commission of an act prohibited
by the order may be punishable by a fine of up to as much as
$4,000 or by confinement in jail for as long as one year or both.
An act that results in family violence may be prosecuted as a
separate misdemeanor or felony offense. If the act is prosecuted
as a separate felony offense, it is punishable by confinement
in prison for at least two years.
I might have to shut my phone off. That tweet that tweet be blowing
up. I might have to shut the phone off. Um, okay. Where are we
going next?
This is just all the same things we've read. There's There's
essentially nothing new here at all. Okay. Possession of a firearm
or ammunition while this protective orders in effect may subject
the p the respondent to federal criminal penalties. It is unlawful
for any person who's subject to a protective order to knowingly
purchase, rent, lease, or receive as a loan or a gift from another
a firearm for the duration of this order. Interstate viol uh
interstate violation of this order may subject you to federal
criminal penalties. This protective order is enforceable in all
50 states, the District of Columbia, tribal lands, and US territories.
Oh, damn. They signed a treaty for it. You can't go to some Indian.
You s you can't go to some Indian
reservation
and get off the hook. Okay, we've got the Wake Wilder reaction.
We've got the Papa Gut reaction. We've got the Braxton reaction.
If there are more reactions, thank you Vain very much. There
are more reactions, send them over. We'll go over the reactions
shortly after finishing reading the documents. Okay. And we're
basically done. Written admission on ineligibility to possess
firearm or ammunition. So basically they go and say we want you
like to write an affidavit out for us that says you understand
your rights now and how they're curbed. Okay.
Um suspension of license to carry a handgun. If the defendant
has a license to carry a handgun, the court hereby suspends the
license for the duration of this order and orders the clerk to
of the magistrate court, sorry, to send a copy of this order
to the appropriate division of the Texas Department of Public
Safety at its Austin headquarters. See the address below. findings
in findings in compliance with federal law. The court finds the
respondent is disqualified. This is all to do with like saying
that at no level are you allowed to use a gun. It's like I think
they have to make this clear that like you're not just barred
from guns in Texas. You're barred from guns everywhere. You don't
get guns. You are done with guns. You you get nothing for the
duration of this order, right? They make it very clear. This
is all, by the way, I don't even think Texas would have a state
rule like this, but it is just the federal penalties. like when
you get into this stuff, you you immediately lose your right
to own guns federally.
Okay, hold on. Uh we do have the Braxton tweet as well. We will
go over that after we cover the rest of the Braxton segment.
Okay.
Um Junar, can you check for me? Did the Braxton tweet come out
before his statement on stream? What order should we watch those
in? Cuz I'm actually not
So, confidentiality of information. This is basically saying
that um
for the addresses listed for the addresses Teone can't go near
the 200 yards or more thing. Those addresses are confidential.
So they hide those orders to the clerk of the court.
The handgun thing 24 hours the court issues this order
regarding law enforcement assistance. If this order excludes
the respondent from the residence and the applicant or the person
granted possession of the residence request assistance, the court
orders the sheriff, constible, or chief of police to provide
a law enforcement officer to accompany the applicant. It's basically
saying you never have to face the person who you have the restraining
order against alone.
Duration of the protective order. Big big. Okay.
So this order expires on blank. This date cannot exceed two years
from the date this order is signed. So this is the standard one
they go to. Okay, in Texas,
2 years is the standard maximum.
This is another
big thing. Okay, two years is the standard maximum. This is why
you know that there was actual evidence. This is why you know
it's not just made up. They would not go this far beyond the
standard maximum without significant evidence. Okay.
So normally two years you just check this box. It expires on
this date.
B is the option B is this order expires on blank. which date
is a more than two years from the date this order is signed because
the court finds that respondent caused serious bodily injury
to the applicant. uh respondent was subject of two or more previous
protective orders or the respondent committed an act consult
con constituting a felony offense involving family violence against
the applicant or member of the applicant's family or household
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah okay but it is C it is not
that and they'll say why so the court issues this order under
article 7B3
code of criminal procedure therefore this order is effective
until midnight on January 23rd 2036
boom Boom. Okay.
2036. 10 years.
10 years.
Now,
I believe this is mostly for the stuff.
Very lucky that he didn't get the the last one here. Okay, that
is everything for this. I think the last thing we have is the
appendix um appendix B. Oh, wait. There is this also the stalking
protective order. This is another additional, you know, appendex
thing. In lie of a finding that family violence occurred, the
court finds that probable cause exists to believe that the respondent
committed an offense under section 42.072
penal code stalking. And the nature of the scheme and or course
of conduct engaged in by respondent in committing the offense
indicates that respondent is likely in the future to engage in
the conduct prohibited by this section. Therefore, the court
grants the application and enters this protective order against
respondent.
So, it does seem like they're saying, "Well, we we do think it's
likely that he would stalk her again,
unless we legally bar him from doing so." Like, unless we say
unless this this order comes about. >> Believe he will
not let this go.
>> Anonymous, thank you for the gifted sub.
>> How far are we from another hour? I believe we are four
subs from another hour right now. No, no, no, no, no, no. Three
subs from another hour right now.
Okay. Exhibit A, we went through this earlier. Exhibit B. This
is with regards to costs. It is ordered that a judgment is awarded
to blank. This is uh Pinky Chu in the amount of $15,000 for reasonable
attorney's fees, expenses, and costs with interest at 6.75% per
year compounded annually from the date the judgment is signed
until paid. The judgment for which led execution issue for which
led execution issue is awarded against John Robertson. This teeone
respondent and respondent is order the respondent and respondent
tectone is ordered to pay these fees.
costs and interest by cash, cashier's check, or money order,
by electronic funds, or mailed directly to uh Pikachu. Pikachu
may enforce this judgment for fees, expenses, and costs by any
means available for the enforcement of a judgment for debt.
Wow.
Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. And then there's uh basically proving
that they've got service and stuff. Okay. So, there's one more
document and that's just, you know, this is the packwatch moment
as we like to call it.
We have the actual affidavit from Teone that he signed saying,
"Yeah, you can't have guns no more, bro. Can't have guns at all,
man. We take them. They gone." That's this guy right here. Okay.
Wait, did I Oh, I opened the wrong document. That's why I'm like,
"Wait, there's there's doc information here." This Okay. No,
we're fine. We're fine. We're fine.
Open the wrong thing. There we go. Oh, I didn't redact this one.
Hold on. Oh, I know what I'll do. All right. This is easy. This
is easy. This is easy. This is what I This is why I didn't redact
it because I was just going to do this. We're good. We're good.
We're good. We're fine. We're fine. We're fine. We're fine. This
is the last thing
So, this is him acknowledging that he knows he can no longer
have firearms. So, firearm affidavit. I understand that I, Tekone,
am prohibited from possessing and or receiving firearms under
federal law 18 USC 922G
1 to9 or N. I tee do not have any firearms or ammunition in my
possession or in my residence. I Tectton acknowledge that firearms
may not be owned by, loan to, rented by, or borrowed by me. I,
Tetone, also understand that actual or constructive possession
or receipt of a firearm by a prohibited person is punishable
by a term of imprisonment of 5 to 10 years and by a fine of not
more than $250,000.
I swear under the penalty of perjury that all the information
is true and correct. Then he signed sworn and subscribed before
me the undersigned authority on this day the 27th day of January
2026. This notorial act notarial act notary notary notarial act
was an online notoriization.
Okay. Boom. There it is. Like actual packwatch moment. Okay.
Lost his guns. Guns are gone. Tactical Tactical Templar said
this couldn't happen. He was Tactical Templar doesn't know about
the 2024 decision. Okay. Uh, hold on. Where do we have it
Is it Raheem? It is Raheem. United States versus REM. >> Just
be your P. >> Can we keep pulling this up cuz it is >> Ben
Ruben donated $3. He should have checked himself before he reconed
>> Thank you so much, Ruben Ruben, for the pun. I appreciate
it, man. Techone this guy for lying for so long, constantly harassing
this woman until she had to take matters into her own hands.
All
huge, huge stuff. All right, without further ado, you know, techone,
microone, tone, as some have called him,
you know, packw watch on that guy. But we, we've kind of dealt
with him now. Okay, we're going to have to go look at some of
the sweeper, some of the sweeping going on in the sidelines.
All right, some of his friends just can't let it go. They can't
can't let it go. Okay, first, hold on. Wake Wilder. Apparently,
Wake Wilder had a good take. Wake Wilder is in fact woke Wilder.
So I expect him to have like the take you >> and everyone's
zeroing in on like the
No. No. I mean that's a little bit >> Like dunking on techone.
And everyone's zeroing in on like the thing. And to me,
by the way, I I haven't seen actual literal evidence of the thing
other than the allegations from Fe. I didn't see like testimony
insisting on this. I'm just saying. Like eh like just saying
I there are normal people with my who are taking strays there
you know I don't
guys won't you just think about the dudes with for a second guys
with catch L's all the time okay could we just leave the dudes
alone
by the way before you say what you think you're going to you
want to say I do believe Wakeer is strapped okay I think Wig
Wilder got a hog because uh he used to do yeah Only Fans. Somebody
told me he used to do Only Fans. So like that's not what's happening
here. He's just he's that guy. That's who that guy is. >> I
don't want anyone to feel like people don't like Techone because
of the you know they don't like him because of the you know uh
the
>> the uh coercion you know. >> Well yeah the whole
multiple
thesults. Yes. Coercion. That's better. That guy went aggressive
with >> the is is is the lowest possible dunk in my opinion
when the guy's like actually a deplorable human, right? Um really
kind of makes the
really kind of takes away from the Okay, you're somebody who's
rich for the you're like, "Well, did you notice?"
Really takes away from it. Guys, don't focus on the
>> You know, Wake Wilder. Wake Wilder be like when when
Wilder said, you know, him having a makes the seem less bad.
I was like, "Whoa, that's a doozy take, Wake." But I'll I'll
leave you to it. Okay, you cook. I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
stand with you in that one. >> Like that. That's That's
the real like interesting one. Um
but like it's too tempting. It's the same thing. It's like Nikki
might have gained a little weight, but she also gained a lot
of um
>> you know, like but then again, you have the inverse,
right, where people are like Donald Trump and everyone's like
we don't they don't no one cares. No one cares about Donald Trump,
you know? Yeah, we both. >> So maybe you have to attack
something like the cuz maybe that's the only thing that'll get
like the machismo dudes who don't have like the processing power
to consider policy to stop thinking he's cool. I don't know.
You know,
>> wake. He's going to start tweeting about you. What?
What is is tech going to be like this wake that told people not
to make fun of my like I
probably be more upset about you talking about his multiple I
would guess. If I had to guess it seemed like that was the thing
he was I've never even seen him try to correct a microphone comment
before. Okay. I've never seen that. I do see him constantly freaking
out about people saying that he's raped. though. Uh very very
very
micro tonedeaf comments from Wake. Okay. Very raped deaf comments
from Wake. Okay. He's he doesn't care about Techton's paint.
Messed up.
>> Like is that is that is that what you're going to take?
Okay. Wait. Do you want me to run that one back? Sorry for defending
something beyond your control and zeroing in on the things within
your control. My god, dude.
Final recommendation for Wake Wilder. Hey, Techtoone, just stop.
People will like you if you just stop. Just stop. Techto, could
you just for two seconds? Stop. We would love if you could stop
for two seconds. Okay.
Someone pointed out that this guy looks like H. He does sort
of look like H. If you just take the head, the head alone,
he's like gigachad. Super tall H. Okay. H plus a foot and a half.
Both above and below the waistline. Okay. All right. We should
continue without making simple comments about random streamers.
Okay, we should just keep going. Oh boy. Oh boy.
Going to get in trouble. All right, we're going to look at the
other Bra comments. Okay, we looked at the first Bra comment
where he talked about Pikachu being mentally ill and because
he's a All right, and then apparently he went and opened up some
of these documents and he started realizing that, hey, these
are these don't look so good, man. These actually don't look
so
He's uh these guys. This does not look good at all. Is this techie
sweeper? This is one of his friends who originally said, you
know,
I don't know why he would say this cuz realistically
I don't even I don't even think this guy would believe it. It
was just bizarre. He said, "I'm going to have to see cuz I don't
trust Biscip. I'm going to have to see what where the documents.
I'm going to have to see them myself." And Pikachu is like a
bunch of mental problems and I think she could have just lied.
She might have just lied through the whole case.
It's like, bro, why why
why would you say that? Why would you say that at all?
Okay, so he starts reading through some of this.
By the way,
just to be clear, what he is reading is one-sided evidenceless
testimony from Pikachu. Okay?
So, if this guy isn't a This shouldn't actually change his mind
at all. This is the same as the statement she made on Twitter
for all intents and purposes. Okay.
Now, I believe her. I believe she had more evidence to back this
to back this up, but we haven't seen that yet. So, he shouldn't
have moved. He only moved because he is a spineless
just to be clear. So, everybody understands that. That's the
only reason he would have moved on this.
That's these are just allegations. The same allegations she laid
out on Twitter. Slightly more graphic. And I'm so I'm so done
with people thinking, "Oh, you filed something in a court document.
That just makes it true." That's not the case, man. That is just
not the case.
>> Ask Chud Logic. Does Chud I I don't know Chud Logic.
Are they in Gotcha or what?
Gaka. Got Gotcha. Okay. I'm trying to make a Gawk joke. I can't
make it work.
This is this is uh this is
now
like he was trying to say you guys are emotional. He was trying
to do the Nicholas Light thing. That's what he was trying to
do, right?
And he just read allegations. I say this is somebody who believes
Pinky Chu. I believe this did happen. I believe everything she
said. I believe that is true. Right? But for him,
Gacha, why did I Dude, I just it was there and I just couldn't.
But
for him, it shouldn't make a difference. It really shouldn't.
Twitter audio is too loud. I have it turned up for other videos.
It's not just Twitter audio. It's like I had to do it randomly
for each video. Every video has its own audio level. >> This
is really [__] up. It [__] sucks to know
this. It really does. I wanted to wait to read everything, but
I don't even I don't even need to read the I'm going to read
the rest. I don't even need to read the rest. Wait for Tech's
response. I'm I'm not taking anyone's
YouTuber Twitch streamer opinion. Just the documents. That's
all I want to see. I want to see official legal documents. I
didn't want to do this on stream because I felt like I would
get like I don't know emotional about it. Uh I don't know if
you Oh, obviously it does, Matt. Obviously there's credence given
to these these comments, but there's also a chance, okay, small
that what they really found was that he was harassing her after
the fact after she'd filed for the protective order, right? Or
after, you know, she'd made the allegation. They might have found
that he was like because I do believe and one of the allegations
made and I I can't remember where I saw this if it was in I think
it's in oh it's in it's in her standard you know her first filing
I believe when she makes the allegations but before she makes
the allegations on Twitter and then it I think multiple months
go by and then she files for a protective order. I think when
she originally made the allegations, he threatened to release
some of her revenge. If she has documented evidence of that,
that would be enough to get this order right. I think would it
be 10 years? I'm not totally sure.
That could be. It's possible that that's where this focus is.
Right
now, the court said they find it likely that he assaulted her.
I don't know exactly what that means because I haven't seen the
evidence of that. They saw some evidence. Maybe it's them inferring
from the fact that he was threatening to revenge her, that he
was constantly like like raging about her on his stream. Maybe
they read into it. I don't know. I'd have to see how they made
their
>> I don't I This sucks. Sucks. I feel bad. I I jumped
the gun for sure. I want to I want to see everything. I I want
to see everything, which is why again I was waiting to comment
on it. I didn't realize there was so many people that wanted
me to talk about it. So, I uh I thought that I would just be
fine to play games and uh and just, you know, wait until everything
was out, but I I didn't realize how many of you guys were waiting
for my my thoughts. So, that that's on me. I'm sorry, guys. I
Hey, you should they you shouldn't have given your thoughts.
I
man I hope I hope if I ever get to become like a big streamer,
let's say I'm I'm at like two to 5,000 concurrent, I hope I know
that if like somebody gets caught on some that I'm friends with,
I hope I just go I can't comment on that. I haven't seen enough.
I I can't comment on that. I haven't seen it. I'll look into
it after this. I can look into it. I'll see I'll give you my
opinion. But for now, I if I haven't seen anything, just shut
up, man. I plead the fifth. I you know, I I don't have to talk
to you. I know my rights. I know my rights. I don't have to speak
to you guys.
Right. W sweeper. It's not even sweeping. Well, unless you're
talking about him. He is sweeping a little bit. But you just
don't comment until you know, right? That's all. You just don't
comment until you know. But he commented and he looks so stupid
for commenting on Pinky Choose mental illness. Not Tees, only
Pikachu.
and then looking at the documents that were already out before
he made the statement and going, "Oh, I retract everything."
Like, bro, you don't retract everything. You don't like the response
you got. That's all. You don't you don't retract anything. You
didn't think about this. You were going to sweep for this guy
cuz he was your friend and now you got a really negative response
to that. You realize you're
just trying to back up as fast as you >> I um I don't know
what to say. It sucks. I think I will say for what it's worth,
guys, for what it's worth, I think that trusting Miz with everything
he's done as a I I think that
with everything he's done,
I just This is where all of these people will fall. Okay. Every
single person who tries to go, "Well, Miskf's really bad, too.
Miskf like Misk is totally worse than Tekone, isn't he?" I don't
see evidence of that.
I I don't see evidence of that. I think Miz I think Miz had
a mutually abusive relationship where he was more abusive than
the other person. That's what I think about Msk. Okay. And I
think people can have those relationships and grow as people,
go to therapy, get help, and become better people. And I don't
need to hold that against them for the rest of their lives. Okay.
Uh I I have that clip in the docket place. Don't worry. I've
got that clip in the docket. But I've not seen that from Techone.
And everybody who deflects to Miz when Miz I've seen Miz go,
"Oh yeah, that happened, that was really bad. I shouldn't have
done that. It was [__] up of me." I've seen him do
that with at least a few of his things. I've never seen Teone
say that. I've never seen Teone take even one iota of responsibility
for any bad thing he's done. Hey, uh, we could go to that not
so internet humanizing interview. Hey, like, have you made mistakes
on the internet? Yeah, my mistakes were I trusted people too
much.
I liked people too much. I trusted them too much. Shut up, Teone.
Okay.
Awful, awful person. And anybody trying to deflect to Miskf.
But Miskf Misk's really bad. Don't you know about how bad Miskf
is?
Losers. All of them. Every single person who does it is a total
loser. More Pegasus complete loser. Braxton complete loser. Nicholas
Light complete loser. All of these people are losers. If you
can't talk about this without talking about Miskf, you are a
loser. Okay, that's it. That's all.
Mis slandering you. I hope not. Uh, I'm not going to watch that
right now. We'll watch it a little bit later. Okay. All right.
Perfect. Perfect. Perfect. Are you on with this clip? This is
apology.
No, no, no. This is the the previous clip. Whoops. >> It
makes sense that Miz would want to see Techie's downfall. And
I don't like >> that he did that, but I understand why
this had to come to light. And I hate it. I [__]
hate that it's it's real. I hate that it's real. I wanted Miz
to be wrong so bad. A bad person could be right about another
bad person. Yeah.
It's true.
This doesn't do much. But
dude, I
I'm on Twitch. I can't. The TLS prohibits me from comment on
this this sufficiently. That little move right there.
>> This doesn't do much. But >> I feel I feel personally
attacked by this guy now. Um, this doesn't do much. I'm gonna
unfollow him on stream. I'm going to unfollow him on stream.
Shut.
Dude. Dude. I
Holy. That just like sent my heart rate through the ceiling.
Just watching that happen. I'm like, I immediately want to start
yelling
horrible things about this person. Like, that's a thing. Is he
still following or was it 100%? No. No, it was he he was like,
"Oh, I don't know if this does much, guys. I've got I'm going
to unfollow Tech Toad on this stream." Oh, look, I unfollowed
Tech
>> No, that doesn't do anything. That literally doesn't
do anything. That is you just trying to signal, please stop me
to your audience. That's all you're just trying to say to people,
hey, stop. Stop. I I fully disavow.
It's tragic. Tragic to watch, man.
Very very gross. I'm not a fan. Okay. I'm not a fan,
>> OH, YOU'RE EVEN GOING TO BLOCK HIM? OH MY GOD. SO, SO
OH, we're totally forgiven for trying to denigrate the victim
in this case. Yeah, absolutely. You block Tech now. That makes
it all fine, bro.
He's just he's self sweeping, right? That's all it is. He's just
self sweeping. That's all he's doing. Now I see why other people
are getting mad about this cuz his apology when he actually comes
out and like says, "Oh, I read it now and now I'm wrong."
That's even worse. This is even worse.
I don't give a [__] about what you do, Teeone. Follow
Teone for all I care. All right.
Apologize to the person that you you tried to
uh I'm not going to say defame. Apologize to the person whose
allegation you cast out on because your friend is your friend.
That's what you should do. Apologize to them for [__]
with them.
Ah, whatever. We keep watching. We keep watching. Oh, he's just
going to Oh, he just pulls up the whole Okay. Very cool. Very
cool. Just pull up a bunch of information on your stream. Yeah,
live. Why not? Uh, guys, I actually, you know, I feel really
bad for Pink. I'm going to pull up the whole thing. I'm going
to pull it up right now. I'm going to give away all this stuff.
I'm going to I'm going to leak all of this.
Uh
that that uh that was the portal for the legal thing and I think
if you click through that I'm pretty sure if you click through
that you get her full name and everything.
So very cool from that guy to go and you know fully dox pink
on his stream. Very very awesome. W that guy. I I think probably
that might be something where it's like okay we're cooked on
that one now, right? It might we might be cooked on that one
cuz I think probably a bunch of big streamers are going to cover
it, right? Public figure. Uh you can't dox a public figure just
because they're a public figure.
Uh and he probably is just too stupid to understand what's going
on there. It's like different if I do it. It's it's something
if he does it. It's different if I do it. Um
yeah, there's no public interest in knowing her name. There's
no there there isn't a public interest served by learning her
name through any of these documents or any of this case. Um,
that is in the latest filing of the protective order kriger that
you're talking about.
Um, he probably he probably didn't mean to. So, I'm going to
hold back on that one a little bit. Now, we do have to read his
tweet. He had a tweet following this up. Do I have it here? Oh,
I just closed.
Uh, I'll just go to his thing. Braxophone. Braophone.
Here it is. So, this is his tweet after he ended his stream.
Okay.
TLDDR. I've read the court documents and form my own opinion
on the matter. Even though Teone helped me while I was going
through difficult times, knowing now what has come to light about
him, I do not want someone like him in my life and I don't want
to be associated with him. All you had to do, by the way, all
this guy had to do was just shut up. I will never go after somebody
who doesn't like who doesn't make public statements who just
says like, "Hey, I was close to this person." I don't think it's
appropriate. This is why I I've made this decision everywhere,
okay? I don't think it's appropriate to take like the closest
friends away from somebody even if they're accused of something
monstrous as long as they don't comment or denigrate any of the
victims. You know what I mean? Like just I'm fine with you having
your own like, you know, your two or three friends, whatever,
your couple friends, your family who don't get harassed for not
burning you at the stake. I think that's appropriate. I know
a lot of people don't agree. A lot of people want from the closest
friends. They want like full disavowels, especially on the internet.
I don't think it's appropriate, but this guy forced himself into
this situation by making incredibly stupid statements about Pink
and about the case. So, he forced himself into this.
I would never try to force somebody to do this. If he just if
he just not said anything, I would never have been aware of him.
I would never have said anything about him. It wouldn't have
been a big deal,
uh I apologize for any unfair assumptions I made about Pink,
and I hope she gets the justice and healing she deserves. When
someone approaches you during a low point and offers you a hand,
most of the time you take it, especially if that person's worst
crimes you knew of were disagreeing with others. I confided in
TechOne because in a space full of fake ass people trying to
do whatever they can for clout and money. He felt like a very
genuine person to me and extended his hand. For what it's worth,
I really think I I really think I needed that because I've struggled
with finding real people who wouldn't lie to me or dodge me if
YouTube/ Twitch views didn't line up with theirs, especially
since co YouTube especially is a very lonely job. From there,
even though we weren't super close friends, I always felt like
he was one of the few creators I had or I had met who had my
back. And whenever he was wrapped up in a controversy before
he was start before he started grifting hard, I always chocked
it up to Twitter being full of people who need other people to
make decisions for them, which is still true. There's a ton of
very loud people like that, but obviously not everyone. And he
was always good at explaining his thought process.
Yeah, this doesn't necessarily
Bro, I
Hey, before he started grifting hard, it's just a weird admission
today out of nowhere. Hello.
So talks about how it's a lonely job. Says Tecton's good at explaining
his thought process. I think he's pretty good at making you believe
stuff. I I don't know if he's
uh it's just rough, man. That doesn't mean
innocent of stuff. That's all I'll say.
And you're acknowledging the grifting. I Dude, this is just a
weird counter signal like against what you were just saying.
I don't know.
Uh we'll keep reading. I stopped hanging out with him pretty
much full stop a bit after the Charlie Kirk incident because
after that he went full extremist right-wing griff mode. I can
be friends with people who have differing political opinions,
but when it things get extreme, I'm not good at handling it.
While I had heard things about pink, even if I didn't think too
much of it since it wasn't my business, those impressions still
stuck with me. It's not a secret that most streamers and YouTubers
who have made it big in the past 5 to 10 years struggle with
some sort of depression, anxiety, or have something else going
on with them. In my case, it was ADHD, anxiety, and depression.
The rest of the industry surrounding content creators also struggles
with mental health. It's not an excuse, but it is a contributor
to why some people act certain ways. I just took his word for
how his relationship with Pink was since they were together for
a time. I also wasn't aware of Tekone schizophrenia, which apparently
was public, but I just never really went looking for it.
I, by the way, I'll all I'll solve by just not responding by
just being like, I'm not going to talk about that. I haven't
looked into it. I haven't looked into that enough to comment
yet. saved this entire post. All of this like all of this out
could have been saved. I haven't looked into this enough to comment
yet. That's all you got to do, man.
I don't need to know about your mental health struggles. I don't
need to know about any of that. All you had to do was say, you
know what? I'm going to opt to shut the [__] up for
two seconds. That's all you had to do.
How is it hard?
I probably shouldn't have taken his word for it, but I also didn't
really think there was a reason for him to lie to me about it,
especially given the fact that there was no trial or case or
anything like that at the time. Either way, that was a poor judgment
on my part. He might not have lied to you about stuff. She could
have been depressed. It's just irresponsible. It's He's getting
He's like, "Listen, she might not be she might not have any mental
illnesses and then I'm wrong." No, you're wrong for commenting
on them in the first place. It's not that you're wrong that Teone
told you about them. You're wrong on commenting them on them
with regards to a sexual assault civil matter, right? They're
not relevant. Unless you know they're relevant, don't bring them
up. Just keep it to yourself.
If Tee was assaulted, we wouldn't say, "Well, Tone's like schizophrenic,
so we need to make sure that a real human being assaulted him
before anything." You don't think he did that? You don't think
he went to a lawyer and was like, "Hey, I, you know, I have some
stuff going on, but here's like why I think this happened." You
don't think somebody would do that?
Right. Anyway, and by the way, I have no idea what what
Pink's situation is. I'm saying regardless of what her situation
is.
Right. Regardless of that,
you don't have to bring it up. Why? Just get some information
that makes it relevant. Dreamers get RLHF brain so hard. I don't
even know what that is. What is that? What is that acronym?
Reinforcement learning. Reinforcement learning from human feedback.
like they're being audience captured is what you're saying. Is
that what you're saying, Cy? That sounds like what you're saying.
Hard to say. Difficult to say.
we continue. I don't even know how to properly describe how I'm
feeling right now. Sad. Disgusted. Kind of just feels like all
of the above. It sucks to have someone you thought was a good
person putting on an act online actually turn out to be someone
with multiple masks. Ah, tell me about it, brother. It sucks
to put your trust in someone who had your back for so long to
find out that they're not the person you thought they were. I'm
disappointed. I'm angry. I'm sad. I'm disgusted. And I'm sorry.
I'm not sorry I didn't immediately choose a side because I still
believe the right thing to to have done was to wait until the
documents were out to make an unbiased decision.
Yes. Sure. But I'm sorry to Pink for making assumptions about
her. Yes. And I'm sorry to my audience because I've never had
any intention of hurting or betraying any of you guys. But after
reading through everything, not taking aside in this and choosing
not to comment on it for the the most part, uh, comment on it
for the most part, definitely wasn't harmless. And it likely
hurt a lot of you guys for me to remain friends with him until
now. This is gay. This is loser commentary. You are You suck.
You weren't ever a real friend. You love Tetone cuz you said
he he felt like a real friend. You were never a real friend if
this is your approach. Oh, I actually I I should have been looking
to disavow this guy way before this, guys. No, that's not true.
You don't have to do that. You technically in some cases could
have like a murderer be your friend and just say, "Listen, guys,
I'm not commenting on that." It's close to me. I'm not commenting
on it. To be honest with you, I would be biased because this
person helped me out a lot and I'm not going to comment on it.
I think it'd be irresponsible for me to give my commentary publicly
because of my bias. That's all you got to do. Hey, I'm going
to lean in this person's direction because they help me with
personal things. It would be irresponsible for me to comment.
That's all you have to do. If you're not willing to dive into
it, if you're not willing to be informed, just say, "I'm too
biased to comment. I'm sorry. Um, if you guys want an update
in six months, I'll give you an update in 6 months." Something
like this, right?
But it's because you made the comments on Pink that were based
on statements from Tactone because of your bias that now you've
done this entire exercise,
entire embarrassing, godforsaken
My goodness, man.
Anyway, I've made the decision to cut him off uh cut him out
of my life going forward. I've also messaged Pink privately to
apologize. I don't know that there's much else to say. There
really isn't. But he continues anyway.
There's a clip going around of me mentioning Pink's mental health
issues, saying it's possible she lied in court and then saying
I want to wait until the documents come out. I'm not even that
big of a creator, so or anything, so I don't think it's going
to get that big, but just know if you see it, that was me before
reading the case. You're dumb. All right, cool.
That does not represent my current thoughts, and it was poor
judgment on my part. I shouldn't have let the fact that Teone
was previously a good friend to me obstruct my vision. Again,
I still believe waiting for the documents was the right thing
to do. I don't particularly think Miskip is the best person to
be sourcing information like that from, especially given the
situation he's in with Emmy. This doesn't necessarily mean anything.
You're just you're literally
like, guys, I should not have let my previous bias cloud my judgment.
But anyway, back to letting my previous bi bias cloud my judgment,
right?
Uh, guys, I probably should have just looked at the information
and not let my previous bias cloud my judgment. I really think
my previous bias on this guy is totally correct and I'm I'm totally
happy to let it cloud my
Why? Just why, man? Just why? Just why, dog? Why was this required?
What are you doing
anyway? Um, but implying that there was even a possibility of
pink lying goes to show how much No, that's not again that's
not right.
I there's always a possibility of somebody lying, right? It's
how you treat the two parties based on your bias. You minimized
or denigrated Pink and you said Teone helped you, right? You
were you were minimizing and denigrating of Pink and her mental
health while not knowing anything about Teone. You didn't have
a good look at the situation. You made the comments. You did.
It's not just pointing out the possibility that she was lying.
It was basically trying to cast out cast dispersions on her.
That's the problem.
Anyway,
we keep going.
Um,
but implying that there was even a possibility of pink lying
goes to show how much I didn't want to believe Teone did something
so horrible despite the writing being on the wall.
Man, now I'm looking for the Where's the Miskf response? I think
Msk responded to this one.
I It's just It's a little immature, but it's funny. Oh, did he
delete? Maybe deleted. I believe Miscuit followed this up with
like what 28-year-old man has stuff like this in his room or
something like that. He basically called him a which, you know,
very funny. Very funny. Anyway,
all right. So, that's the all for the Braxton stuff. I think
we've got a pop of gut comment here. And I'm looking around.
I'm trying to find out, do we find any comments from other people
that we could throw in here. If you guys know commentary that
I've missed so far, go ahead.
Huh? Rape tone. Biggest sweeper on Twitter is gone again. Templar's
voice. Tactical Templar taken out by the woke left again. No
way. Templar's voice. Let's see. Check it out. Account
Uh, we do it again.
We Hold on. Hold on.
Little bit little bit shorter this time.
>> Oh, this is not Templar's roar. My bad. It is Templar's
roar.
>> We don't We don't need this song. All right. Going over
the Techone files plus Ilanomar fart sprayed. Gross.
Okay,
now this might be funny. The Tactical Templar stream could be
very, very funny. All right, three hours ago, Tactical Templar
stream. This could be very interesting. All right,
we might have to check it out. What is he saying about the Teone
stuff today? Three hours ago. We'll have to look. All right,
this is Tactical Templar. If you don't know who that is, Tactical
Templar is in fact
spiritual adviser. Oh, he's hiding replies. I see. So, he hid
the miskf reply. Hold on. Where's the miz reply here? It's got
to be here somewhere. Oh, it's not here. Is it under the other
one? It's under the other one, isn't it? Isn't it, Braxton? Hold
on. view. I can't Why can't I view hidden on this? I can't view
hidden on this. Oh well.
All right. He is hiding replies. I'm getting pretty I'm pretty
sketched up by free scrolling um hidden replies though. Some
reason when I Google Templar's voice, the very first link is
this Templar's voice. Fantastic insight. Oh, wait, hold on. I
thought he was banned. Does this pop up? Oh,
my comments anytime I post a Gavin meme and then he did some
comment here. Okay. All right. All right. All right. All right.
Okay. I think we're ready to go with uh the next part. We're
going to go to the Papa Gut thing, guys. Again, any commentary
from other people other than the Tactical Templar stuff, which
we will go to shortly. All right.
Send it my way. Put it in the content link section of the Discord.
Put it anywhere you can.
Dude,
wait. Is this a berserk? Is this a berserk background?
Dude, let's go.
Let's go. Bro, I'm really digging the penguin avatar recently.
Okay, the penguin avatar is a vibe.
Penguin avatar. Total vibe,
guys.
You have no idea what you've created. You have no idea what you've
created. You have no idea. Okay,
it's a vibe. Where are we going next? Asold defends Heone despite
admitting that he had knowledge of the evidence that would ultimately
lead the court to rule on behalf of his victim. What?
What? Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. What? Hold on.
That can't be true. >> And these people falsely accuse
me of
and you've let it go on for years. >> I think this is the
main reason why TeeOne has become so extreme.
And whenever you think about it, really calling somebody a is
one of like the top three things that you can say to somebody
that is career destroying, career ending, or damaging. And so
when
>> top three Oh, when is the clip from as well? Cuz I think
I think this one's an older It looks like the current background,
but I've heard him say this. >> You have an entire group
of people that are really with no evidence.
No evidence at all saying that Teeone is a
tone and bling, well tead.
His dad had this thing happen with the military. Like think about
how disgusting that is really if you said that. Like and really
think about can you imagine what it would be like if somebody
like Tee said, "Well, look at
>> Don't make me defend Teone. This is a >> this
person. They must be a criminal because their their dad is a
criminal or their other family member is a criminal.
>> The the evidence that he's aware of can't be that Teton's
dad had sexual assault charges. That can't be it. Come on, man.
Come on.
It's a joke. The genetic thing, the epigenetic memories of thing,
that's a joke. That's us memeing. We're not saying it serious.
>> That person was black. Do you know what would happen
to that person? They'd be
They would be banned and they should be banned. That's the only
reason why it's been accepted.
>> Come on, man. >> Come on, man. >> They call
him a generational Yes. It's implying generational guilt.
>> it's very funny though. It's very funny. Yeah, I do
remember. >> Say that about somebody who's non-white and
you're going to be taking a very long vacation.
>> Depends on the platform. >> It's just the truth.
>> I made, you know, when I'm not live on Twitch, I made
jokes about the Warrior Gene. Okay, I've done it. I'm not proud
of that. I'm not proud of it, but I've done it. I haven't gotten
banned. So, seems like Twitter and and Kick are kind of fine
with it. It was a joke. And the point that I'm making is that
>> when you have people that are spread, >> but like
statistically
just paying. >> It's all a joke. It's all a joke. >> Reban
Rubin donated $3
bequeathed his son his most valued delu. >> Thank you very
much for the three Ren Rubin. I appreciate it. I appreciate you.
Thank you. >> At least from his perspective, the court
case is not finished. And so I do know more about it than the
public and I and also I remain to be Tectton's friend and I support
Teone. You can take that for what you want. >> I know more
about it than the public.
>> when you have people that and >> now he's obviously
saying here, which is not implied by the clip or by the title
at all. He's obviously saying what he knows is things that exonerate
Tecton or make make it like more um understandable what Tone
is being accused of. Right. I'm guessing he's talking about the
Frame civil case possibly. And also, by the way,
the one group of people that certainly doesn't know anything
about this and for sure doesn't have any information about this
are the people calling him a Well,
yeah, is what it is. That title is not accurate at all. That's
why I can't get into it, man. You got to do accurate stuff so
then if they ever confront you on it, you don't go, "Oh, well,
uh, no, I don't actually believe in." Right? You got to do accurate
stuff.
That's me personally. I understand that's a stylistic difference,
but it seems important to me. Okay. Do accurate stuff. Accurate
stuff. So then you can laugh and style on TechOne after. Okay.
Yeah. This tweet right here,
this tweet got the Techone seal of approval. All right. Obviously,
if Bumor is kind of hit or miss with her tweets, they can be
funny. Yeah. But I
I just don't like lying about people. I don't feel like I don't
like feeling like I lie about them, you know. So,
all right. All right. Papa gut thing. And then what else we got?
I think we're going to the Papa Gut thing next. Let me go find
that tweet really quick.
There's the Papa Gut tweet. Papa got commentary on the Teetone
stuff. Surely Surely he won't just complain and receive about
Mis.
>> Wait, censored crotch.
Why are you censoring crotch
>> closed and said that my >> Oh, the YouTube That's
probably just the YouTube sensor did it. >> Especially
if it's Why are you censoring >> They turned him on. >> Got
it. Got it, >> bro. Come on, dude. Misk. You You can't
do you. This is this is like the biggest issue here is that based
on the allegations against Teone, Teone might be like a legitimately
abusive piece of
opinion coming out here. >> Totally opinion coming out
here. Um
um you've done bad things. You can't possibly give us good information
on this because you've done bad things before. How about you
just evaluate what he's saying? I understand that you're a lazy
loser. It's evident in everything about your stream and appearance,
BUT YOU TURNS OUT YOU COULD JUST ACTUALLY PAY ATTENTION. TURNS
out you can actually pay attention and look into things and determine
whether the information is good for yourself. Very easy. Very
easy to do.
>> Multiple people sourcing this information. It was not
just Ms. Kif, although Miz was leading the way getting the word
out. Okay. But multiple people sourcing this information. If
you cared to know, you could have made yourself
>> Actually be a legitimately abusive piece of [__]
But every allegation against Teone, like there's a similar allegation
against Msk. There was a whole thing.
>> What? Wait, what?
>> Msk and Tecton's allegations are way different.
Way way way different thing where like Msk where Msk met up with
Emiru and then she started like crying and it turned him on.
So I don't know why you're doing like the Oh,
oh my god. What the? You can't do that.
like you.
>> How do I respond to that?
>> I don't think you know that it's the crying thing that
was doing it
>> cuz he didn't explicitly say that like Techto did apparently.
>> Did he force her? Yeah, that's like the big thing after
is like wait when he realized Emiru actually wasn't into it.
Papa Gut, what happened? What did he do when he realized Emiru
wasn't into it? I forget. Oh, he like jumped backwards and
Right. Was was it he jumped backwards and
he freaked out >> or was it that he held her down and forced
his into her mouth? Cuz one of them is Tekone and one of them
is Msk.
And I I dislike the guy who did the forceful like thing. Okay,
that's who I'm That's the guy I'm not going to ride with. That's
the guy I'm not going to do equivocation for. Okay, me personally
can't do that. >> I was
Oh, bro. I feel like I have to go. Should we get Can we get the
time stamp to the Papa Gut stream? I need the time stamp for
the Papa Gut stream. I need to hear this speak more. I feel like
that is where the content is. Okay. Anything saying I I do think
it's going to be very interesting. I do want to see it. Let's
go.
Um, Msk, you can't you can't deliver this information. Why?
Just read. This is literally her filing. Why do you even have
to take Msk seriously with the things he says? Why are you talking
about Miskf at all?
Thanks all his VODs members only. Why? I know people who can
get around that. I know people who do great work, do heroic work.
Okay.
Hassan covered this stuff earlier today and I am going to check
it out. We'll watch the Hassan reaction. Okay. I saw him cover
the Gat Fumodor tweet,
so we will check it out. >> Techone thanks Ethan Klein
for having his back throughout his recently
>> No, no, no, no, no, no, no. I could easily just buy
the membership. Junarch, but that would be stealing. That would
be like taking his privated material. Okay. But if somebody were
to be recording that VOD and saving it themselves, that would
not be the same thing. Okay. That's like somebody lending me
a VCR tape with their with a recording of a video on it. Okay.
All right. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Yeah. I'm not I'm not that
invested. Just if we if we got it, I'd check it
>> We're right We're right We're right here. Oh my god.
We're on it. We're on it. We're on it. Let's go. Hillary Clinton
Hill Dog into >> Wait, what? >> That is where they
rape. >> What happened?
>> Techone thanks Ethan Klein for having his back throughout
his recently finalized domestic abuse proceedings. >> Wait,
clip and get to him. I just want to thank >> No way. They
found a way to tie this back to Ethan Klein.
>> They found a way to tie it back to Ethan. Ethan supported
Tech Tone. Uhoh. for having my back >> and kind of giving
my perspective and my POV on why I said what I said. Maybe we
don't need to talk, but I at least just want him to know that
I appreciate him being pretty levelheaded and telling his friend,
"Well, this is why Teto did this." Because as a guy who's been
horrifically misunderstood on the internet, I really appreciate
people just, you know, having a level head and being like, "Well,
let me think about this from Teto's perspective." And I very
much appreciate that. >> Here we have >> and I also
hope that him and his wife and sorry, I will call her name Ela
are doing okay. As well as maybe a >> Okay, do I have this
sped up? I don't.
He'd be speeding it up. Oh god. Is Is Han gonna be careful with
these documents if he gets them? Do I have to worry about Hassan
doxing people here? Is Han gonna be careful or do I need to preview
this and figure out where the Do I have to give this time stamp
to
>> I don't know if he's going to be >> scumbags.
All of them. >> Every single one of these animals. >> October
7th. What happened in >> anyone? Well, it's it wouldn't
be intentional. I say docs. It wouldn't be intentional. It' be
like accidentally leaking something, >> you know, days,
weeks, and months. to follow. That's a serious problem. It's
a serious problem
whether it's Israel or the United States and it's a serious problem
for our young
>> and it was frankly >> judge me by my haters and
your haters have been judged. Yeah. The court has officially
found reasonable grounds to believe streamer te committed sexual
assault. He's now banned from owning firearms has been placed
on stalking protective order. Additionally, he will be paying
$15,000 for the victim's lawyer's fees. Teto reportedly admitted
in court he pivoted the onsan and doing right-wing content to
deflect from his assault and stalking charges.
It's now over. Now we have all the real details too. I had to
deal with the >> Everybody did grab that. I should have
watermarked that screenshot. >> These animals for years,
dude. For years they leaned into every goddamn thing they possibly
could to be like, "Oh, Assan is against Israel. He's a anti-semitic
terrorist. He should be shot. He should be imprisoned. He should
be getting detained by the federal government. When I get detained
by the federal government, oh, it's probably fake. He probably
that didn't happen. And if it did happen, it should happen more
uh frequently. I I understand I I maybe need to re-evaluate how
I deal with like Misk and Hassan. I do understand why it's important
to like re-establish with your viewers why the people who are
hating on you are bad. I kind of get it monetarily, but it's
just it's funny seeing them. Yeah. just immediately like the
first reaction is like yes everybody who's ever been mean to
me is a for it is that is the case yes that's how this works
guys
on actually higher proclivity than most streamers for that to
be the case okay
a lot of lot of weirdos hate this guy for some reason it's almost
like it's really easy to farm and to keep your audience looking
in another direction if you just have Hana's bad content all
the time interesting pattern we see unfolding there
interesting I didn't mute him, did I? Nope. Just a lot of dead
air. Okay, fantastic. Fantastic. Here we go. >> You must
feel vindicated now. Their time will come. >> To be fair,
you do this too with Destiny. Do I? Well, possibly. >> Their
time will come. These are objectively evil people. Okay. These
are objectively evil people. They are object
ontologically. One might even say just at a base level, at a
DNA level, evil people. Okay, let's go. >> Monstrous evil
people. And that's precisely the reason why I just keep my head
down and keep doing what I'm doing because I don't want to be
constantly dealing with this dumb nonsense.
He spends a lot of time going over the drama stuff and the nonsense
stuff. But I do appreciate that he went to Minnesota. He handed
out hand warmers. he was out there in a dangerous situation that
not a lot of streamers with his level of clout or money would
put themselves in. I actually do appreciate that. I do think
that's actually doing work on Hassan's part. I do think that's
him stepping outside of his comfort zone. Especially if you remember,
and a lot of people called him a for this after the Charlie Kirk
stuff, he was very much like, I'm not going out. I'm very scared
that something's going to happen, right? It's almost like it'd
be reallyed up to take this guy who is trying to do things, who
is trying to go out and and make a difference. It it would almost
be really up to keep putting in his head the idea that he might
have to worry about that kind of thing, right? To put the idea
of violence in his head to try to with him in that way. Hey,
you're going out and like joining these protests. Uh, somebody
should stalk this guy. It'd be really up to do that, wouldn't
it?
>> Hold on. Somebody you have an entire group numerous
former partners by the way is
tone and blown
must be a look at his dad. his dad had this thing happen with
the military. Like, think about how >> I mean, his dad
was also convicted. I mean, it's not that one is not even an
>> That just makes matters even worse. >> That is
really if you said that like and really think about can you imagine
what it would be like if somebody like Tee said, "Well, look
at this person. they must be a criminal because their their dad
is a criminal or their other family member is a criminal and
that person was black. Do you know what would happen to that
person? They'd be banned.
They would be banned and they should be >> Wait, what?
>> I think was on his phone there.
>> That is a different thing. I also I I hope Assan just
admits this. I think he
>> It's literally just a joke. Just because your dad's
guilty of rap doesn't mean you'll be guilty of rap. It's literally
just a meme.
>> And yeah, it would be probably bad to say somebody because
they're black is like going to be guilty of crime or something.
Yeah, obviously. But that's like we're just making a It's just
a meme, dog. >> The talking.
Yeah. Falsely accusing someone of being a because they're black
is cra like >> Yeah. That's entirely separate from talking
about a person who has numerous allegations from previous partners
and then finding out that their father also had a a similar charge.
Like there's
>> like
being a generational has nothing to do with, you know, being
a black person and then having a a black child. Like what the
this argument is crazy. He's imagine if Teon was black. That
wouldn't that wouldn't change anything if >> he doesn't
want to give it to them that it was just a joke. was black and
his father was black and his father was also found guilty of
raping a court of law as a as a
>> uh as a as a military official and then Teesh former
partners, black te's former partners also did that. That would
have nothing to do with him being black at all. That would have
everything to do with the same dynamic that exists in this circumstance
as well. >> That would have nothing to do with his skin
color.
>> That's the only reason why it's been
>> Yeah, bro. They call her a terrorist. >> That's
true. Wait, that is true. Lucari is just like Tone except he's
black. Okay. So, that is Black Tone is >> another reason
to be Muslim. Yeah. Well, because they don't understand the argument
that I'm making about anti-colonial resistance obviously. And
the fact that I'm Muslim also lets it
>> The amount of >> They call him a generational.
Yes. It's implying generational guilt.
Yeah, it's a joke. It's not I mean it's not a joke because it's
real.
>> Well, it's it is a thing that happened, but it's a joke
as in we don't believe the genetic component is real. >> Also,
uh you know, people are myself included are making jokes about
the fact that there is, you know, generational happening in the
family. >> Say that about somebody who's not >> No,
he's saying we profiled because his father's instead of recognizing
we called him that after credible accusations came out. I know.
Credible accusations that have actually landed him in legal trouble
now. >> Thank God for that chatter. Thank God for that
chatter. Explaining it perfectly. Thank you, Chatter. Thank you,
random Hassan Chatter, for explaining that
>> We were right in white. You're going to be taking a
very long vacation.
It's just the truth.
And and the point that I'm making is
Yeah. Yeah, but then you have to start talking about how behavioral
traits are genetic and how heritable traits probably track with
other traits that are highly heritable. And then you get into
a whole bog, evil Johnny Bravo, of stuff you don't want to talk
about, stuff that is not cool to talk about on a street >> when
you have people that are spreading uh, you know, at least from
his perspective, the court case is not finished. And so I do
know more about it than the public. And I and also I remain to
be Tectton's friend and I support Teone. You can take that for
what you will.
Um,
when you have people that and and also by the way, >> you're
a weirdo. >> The one group of people that certainly doesn't
know anything about this >> and for sure >> Well,
it's just crazy because you had like deep inside knowledge on
this stuff and for some reason you uh I don't know
for some >> um I think Dr. Mike probably had like uh somewhat
the right take. It's like I don't I'll just say I don't know
what the um he's like a little too strong on it for me. I don't
know what like the averages are. I do think there's probably
like averages or something. It's it's to me it doesn't matter.
You everybody the whole point of like a
of a what do you call it? Um like an egalitarian society, an
egalitarian like liberal society is that you're not judged on
that. Doesn't matter. You're just judged by your performance.
You're judged by what you do. So it literally wouldn't matter.
I don't think you'd change anything, right? So it it because
it doesn't matter. I don't want to talk. >> Weird reason.
Despite your deep inside knowledge, you were wrong. And I guess
the people that had outside knowledge that chose to believe the
victims were right. How does that work? >> Or doesn't have
any information about this. Are the people calling him a
>> read the tweet, Hassan. Read the tweet. Read the read
the good tweet. Read the good tweet. Hassan,
>> read it. Read it. Read it. >> Techone update.
The official protective order was filed with Travis County today
as well as Tees affidavit confirming he knows he can no longer
uh possess firearms. Here are the highlights from the documents.
The court finds there are reasonable grounds to believe Techbo
Salt and has stalked Pink. The court believes it is likely the
stalking would persist if he is not legally barred from it. The
protective order persists until January 23rd, 2036. Teone will
pay $15,000 in Pink's lawyer fees. Teone cannot share any photos/vos
of Pink with anyone. Teone cannot communicate with Pink directly
or indirectly except through her lawyer. Teone cannot engage
in any conduct that is reasonably likely to harass, annoy, alarm,
abuse, torment, or embarrass Pink directly. Tech cannot go within
200 yards of Pinkychu or her residence or her place of work.
Tech cannot possess or receive firearms. >> So true, man.
So true. So true.
>> There it [__] is, dude.
Yeah. Also, in the court, he straight up, apparently in the court,
he openly stated that he pivoted to right-wing content because
he had to like continue
farming uh he had to continue farming and continue gaining prominence.
And part of that right-wing content pivot was also attacking
me, including but not limited to using the the the Kaya Gate
as a as a reason for why he was doing
Very cool. Very cool. >> Oh, that was a f
going on. Oh, there's is another Don't know why it's like effing
a miniature. >> I want to see if he's going to go as far
as um other people did. Okay. I want to see if he's going to
go all the way to the point where he's like um will he go all
the way to the point saying like now that Tone has been found
liable for assault, you now know that I didn't shock my dog.
I wonder if he'll go all the way there. It would just be very
funny for me if he did that like in the exact same vein Misk
did. Let's see. Will he do it? Will he go that far?
Is this on?
He's just a Dude. Yeah, we're very
We're very lucky that Ka is not in the room. I believe it was
stream issues that caused the previous Kaya gate. Okay. He was
very He was very agitated. He's very upset. We're very lucky
that Kai is not in the room right now. >> Moment of utter
vindication.
I'm actually thinking this is his dog. I think his dog is very
happy.
>> Also, his son is bad.
>> Did that come through? I whispered some stuff into my
mic. Could you hear that?
>> Not that it matters.
All of the worst scumbags on the internet basically created a
league of villains
and have been
>> on the wrong side consistently. What is this? Oh, this
is the lawyer that is also legal mindset going to bat for techone
with incredible real lawyer arguments like pro- female bias
also jury pool potentially biased towards plaintiff skew heavy
female bias bro there's no jury pool here [__] you
making up dog
you're just making some up the hell what the hell man
you just made it up >> county is >> pro- female bias
outcomes potential activist judge with domestic violence bias
jury pool potentially bias towards plaintiff skew heavily female
bias we haven't seen abusive communications
>> Hey, hold on. What has mentioned earlier? Okay.
>> Not that it matters.
All of the worst scumbags on the internet basically created a
[__] League of Villains.
>> KG about it, right? Like you want to talk about [__]
that happened in 2009 when one of my 30 investors like like
>> sorry we're we're back to we're back to >> and
have been on the wrong side consistently. What is this? Oh this
is the lawyer that is also legal mindset going to bat for techone
with incredible real lawyer arguments like pro- female bias arguments.
Travis County is pro- female bias outcomes. Potential activist
judge with domestic violence bias. Jury pool potentially biased
towards plaintiff skew heavily female bias. We haven't seen abusive
communication. Amazing. Oh, is it effing again?
I have no idea what's happening with my upload speeds. My upload
speeds are gone. My download is fine, but my upload is going
down to zero.
>> Hold on.
Get a new Shimu tweet real quick.
I see no no claims have been made here yet, but there's a new
Shaboo tweet real quick. Just in the background. Okay. Legal
mindset secured a contract with Mythic Talent using Techone.
Legal Mindset is now running cover for Tone after a protection
order has been issued with the judge stating they believe Pink
was SAD. Is Legal Mindset still affiliated with you guys?
I suspect
that this is not the case by the way. And particularly funny
in my mind is that legal mindset very clearly. I actually grabbed
the time stamp yesterday. We went over this on stream because
I wasn't sure. He was being really cavalier about doxing people.
But hold on. I went and grabbed the notes on this. Give me a
second. I just got to find my notepad for this right here.
He says he's sponsored by Mythic still. So I was very confused
because I'd heard that he got booted. I'd heard that he was no
longer affiliated.
>> But yeah, thank you for that. Thank you for that. Um,
I got to have your legal vices, guys. Note it says long long
man came up with everything. Have a reason months and I have
no fine one of these. Reason why I started this early is because
I really wanted to get this out. I kind of have the scoop on
this. >> Uh, and I'm going to cover the tech files in a
way that nobody else does. >> All right, we're doing this
sponsor on the Fast Facts. You're gonna see Delete Me, our first
sponsor courtesy of Mythic. So, thank you Mythic for hooking
me up with Delete Me. It'll be on the Fast Facts. Um,
>> there we go. Delete me from mythic talent directly.
I don't know what delete me is, but very interesting. And yeah,
I don't know. I Is this guy still affiliated with Mythic Talent?
Cuz he definitely represented himself that way on his stream.
I also might not have had to pull that up because it might be
the case that legal mindset in this clip right here actually
says he's >> so of course I joined the uh the talent agency
mythic uh and this put was put out on September 27th so it's
3 days ago which was really awesome. Big thanks to TechTone for
helping me out. He actually got me in contact and let me get
in contact with the leadership, the CEO, the COO.
>> We went over this last night but very suspiciously legal
mindset is not on the Mythic Tal website anymore. Yeah, he's
not. No, we went over this last night watching you back. Not
on the website.
Very interesting. >> It was really awesome to meet them
and to to talk about them. And even Pikachu, this is the this
is the real thing. This is the real thing here. Even Pikachu
said he's not a groomer.
>> Um, guys, just in case you don't remember who Pikachu
is, let me pull up the the context video. This is Pikachu for
the people who don't. Oh, I have it muted. I have it muted. I
have I have to restart it.
first bit known to man. Unfortunately, you guys have been outvoted.
The people who don't like the bit have been outvoted
cataclysmically. Okay, the this is borderline like Russian election
status. Okay, watching that video is Putin and you guys are whatever
dissident get like half a% of the vote. Okay, you guys have been
out voted cataclysmically. There is no chance. You have no shot.
>> So if the girl who issued the temporary protective order
said he is not a groomer, he did not groom me. What does that
say? And what I will say to you guys is this. There's a lot of
buyer
in dating. When you date somebody, you can look back at the stuff
you did and say, "Oh, I have buyer's remorse." Right? And that
sucks. And it sucks that in American law, some girl or man or
whatever, your partner with buyer remorse can come back and hit
you with lawsuits, with penalties, with restraining orders a
year after you dated because they have buyer remorse now on dating
you or maybe on stuff they did with you, right? That sucks. That
sucks because if they did that stuff consensually with you, like
why is that should be dragged through the court of public opinion,
you know? I just I don't I don't see that.
Wow. So true, man. Hold on. Uh just as an aside, this got made.
Um just to be clear, this was already done. Super cursed, turbo
cursed, all of the way cursed, the most cursed image perhaps
on the entire internet. Okay. But I just, you know, somebody
did make it, so I I will pull it up. Very gross. Very, very gross.
Okay. Very gross. Not a fan.
>> So, of course, I I joined the uh >> I do want
to see I do want to know. Wait, is Legal Mindset still affiliated
with you guys? >> Cuz that's that's a little weird. Legal
mindset at mythic talent.com. Yeah, I did not consent to that
image being made. It's kind of [__] up. It was very
[__] up.
So that's that's a story line we're tracking. Okay, we're tracking
this one. Is legal mindset really truly still affiliated with
mythic talent.
It's very concerning. Very Yeah, we don't know,
dude. The stupid these guys use this rabbit to call out every
woman on the internet. Be like, "Hey, you're hitting the wall.
Hey you, [__] Hey, you're hitting the wall. Hey,
you're hitting the wall." And now we get to flip it. Okay, w
script flip. Okay, fantastic stuff. We love We love throwing
this back at them. All right,
it's Guys, your time is up. Your time is up. All right,
the [__] man. The spiral is crazy. He's a decent
guy. He has to be on drugs. Whether is yaba some potentratom
or some [__] something else. Is it just me or does
he look really sweaty? Also, this is sad, fam. Did he have bipolar
in the stream last night? Yeah, we did cover that last night.
I opted not to mock the
Uh, I don't think he pulled up some of the medical documents
from the case, so I will give him that at least. Thank
Thank god. All right, we're back to Hassan for a little bit >> sometimes.
I don't know why it's back up
>> They do not want you to talk about techone. Guys, please
stop around. Okay.
The day the victims of Hosanabi Discord server run by Stalkman
gets leaked is going to be some of the craziest [__]
we've ever seen. I just know it. Oh yeah. You mean the one that's
like uh stalking my family and
>> I know.
>> Oh boy.
>> I know. >> There's that element too.
>> This guy credits Tech for getting him in mythic talent.
>> He does. The amount of I've had to put up with for the
last couple of years is insane, dude. By some of the worst, objectively
worst scumbags. It is crazy.
It It is curious how like a lot of them just seem to have the
weirdest
It's like the easiest lane to pivot into. I'd say I think Asminold
is the only one who doesn't have like super weird allegations.
Who does the Hana's bad stuff consistently?
>> Oh, and uh Ethan Klein. But like other than them Dude,
just all of these like weirdos just are like, "Oh, this is the
easiest lane on the internet
>> every time." >> Shocking to me.
>> yet yet. Okay, >> let's get back to the Tik Tok
purchase. I mean, I guess we already talked about it all up and
down extensively.
>> And I wonder what why that lawyer is defending tech.
>> There's a he does a whole
does a whole stalking segment on
stalking. Sorry. a whole snarking segment. I'm leaving. You look
see it. >> This is Asmin Gold's This is Asmin Gold's talent
agency.
>> And they recently dropped Techone. Even though Asmin
Gold has said nothing about, you know, Teone or hasn't really
said much about Techone for some reason, even though he usually
farms a lot of these like things.
What is this? >> It's hard to come back. It's really hard
to come. I'm gonna [__] cry here. You know, because
when you're when you're super depressed,
when you're super depressed, it's hard to do this. It's hard
to do this [__] you know?
>> And um
>> Jesus Christ, Matt Lincoln, >> I love you guys.
It's really good. It's really good to be back.
It's really good to be back. He thinks he's being chased by Antifa
>> Oh god. Does he pull the Does he pull >> me looking
at this guy? Stop. By the way, this is another like Ethan Klein's
best friend. Legal mindset. Legal
>> Oh god. >> Another Ethan ally.
>> Yeah. Someone throw me the the Candace. This dude who's
not a [__] real lawyer anymore, I'm pretty sure.
Who had a entire series talking about how you can become a u
a tourism expert.
Passport Bro uh Passport Bro Legal Mindset series. This was funny
as actual psychotic episode. He also said he was the Charlie
Kirk of Thailand.
Legal Mindset did a video where he claimed that Antifa spies
were tracking him in Thailand. His evidence for this was that
he saw a white woman at a Starbucks and she didn't smile at him.
The dude is a complete lunatic. I don't know why anyone listens
to him. I think we know why people listen to him.
That's real, by the way. We watched that last night. That's real.
I could literally grab the time stamp. You know what? Why not?
Why not? I know it's fresh in people's minds, some people's minds,
but why not grab the time stamp right now? Take one more quick
look at that. Okay, hold on. Let me go to it. I'll go to it right
now.
Where is it? Right here. Yeah, right here. Okay, this is the
segment from his stream. He was talking about Hassan on the stream,
by the way. >> Hour stuff. >> He cuts to this. Okay,
but anyways, um, so for context, Legal Mindset lives in Thailand
and he thought because of his coverage on the internet, coverage
of Assan, his his recommending that Antifa be labeled a global
terrorist group because of that,
thought he was being stalked by woke white women in Thailand.
Now, listen to him describe his >> Yeah. And then and then
a bunch of uh other woke white women. Like I ran into these two
chicks on the BTS station like I mentioned and they're like obviously
super woke cuz they're ugly and scowlling and like what the [__]
is going on with them and their face they just can't smile like
smile and be polite. I love Thailand because everyone's normally
polite. They're doing the sweaty cup. They're smiling, right?
But now everyone's been mean and maybe it's raining or something.
I don't know what's going on. All right. So, um All right. Abroad
isn't safer. So, this is one thing I want to bring up about Charlie
Kirk, right? Once again, I don't want to be the Charlie Kirk
abroad here, but um but you know, you have to take your own safety
and your own, you know, measure. I believe in safety. I >> Can
I can I sit next to you? Uh what the are you stalking me? Can
I sit here? Uh are you stalking me, bro? How does this guy find
any women that he's not paying for? I don't get it. I just I
literally don't get it. I That's how in my head what's happening.
She like sees another white dude in Korea and she's like, "Hey,"
or sorry, Thailand. She's like, "Hey, what's up, man?" He's like,
"Uh, old white woke woman. What the?" >> Believe in learning
and practicing and implementing safe techniques. If you think
somebody is following you, you should do something like take
an alternative route home. You should take an alternative route
to leave your apartment. You should try to go a different way
because you want to try to shake the tail, right? That's normal.
Maybe there's somebody that's going to harm you or hurt you or
you or kill you. You don't know what they're doing. You don't
know what their intent is because they haven't told you what
their intent is, right? Um, so
you know they they you're supposed to tell somebody right directly
what their your intent is, but they haven't done that.
Now, I should pause here and say because it it does it's something
that's important to me. Maybe it's not important to you guys.
Okay, I will just say he apparently was recently diagnosed bipolar
or recently disclosed that he was diagnosed bipolar. And this
does sound like some kind of psychosis and I for me I personally
don't like making fun of that as much. You guys can use these
uh these clips or whatever's going on here as you like. Okay.
But I I personally I'm I'm going to hold back just >> and
so um one of the things in this this book, Private Dancer. >> Okay.
Anyway, that's uh that's him talking about the woke white women.
All >> Yeah. Illegal mindset is right.
>> Yeah. This is the person who Ethan Klein was talking
about >> talking about a certain movement that has blown
up on the internet that's gotten out there. That's right. It's
the Passport Bros. another one of Ethan's allies that Ethan farmed
aggressively
>> that Ethan Klein was all up and down promoting him to
his audience of women. By the way,
there is possibility to get pretty cheap rent uh in Korea. What
is Korea good for? Korea has really hot women. That's just very
clear. Vietnamese women are extremely hot, but they're also kind
of crazy. Obviously, Thailand very open in terms of basic culture
in Thailand. It's illegal to ask for money in public.
>> We're just we're just going to go snark. This is a snarking
legal mindset stream now. Techone is done. Legal mindset is next.
I believe substance has called it. Okay, this is a substance,
right? Hold on. Where was it? Where was it? Where was it?
Oh, this one. Yeah.
Tick tock. Tick tock. Tik Tok. Legal mindset. Tick tock. Tik
Tok. Tik Tok, my friend.
You're going to start seeing these this rabbit in your dreams.
Okay,
you're next. You're next.
See that? That's the deal. In public, in private, it doesn't
matter. So, in the definition of private is the curtain, right?
To pull the curtain, it's fine. So, just be understand if you're
a guy who wants to do that, that's available to you down there.
Thai women very much like Western men, very open to it. So, yeah,
best sell. Also Korea, one of the capitals of plastic surgery,
there are large breasted women. I have seen personally women
with G-cup.
Very possible. Now mind you, and realistically, if you wanted
to believe this, then what reason could there possibly be for
legal mindset to be against Pinky Chu? Okay, if this is really
the kind of thing that he's into, why in the world would he have
sided with Techone is the real question. >> A lot of them
are wearing padded bras and other things like that. So you do
have to, you know, buy or beware.
>> Another one of Ethan Klein's allies who is of course
defending rapetone. I just want to point that out again. Ethan
Klein, another one of Rapetton's allies. Um, Rapetone personally
thanked Ethan Klein for all the support. Ethan Klein has shown
rapetone.
Just remember, just remember who these gross loser.
>> He doesn't like castles obviously. >> Freaks are
all because Israel. Okay. All because they aligned on
Assan and being pro- Israel. Okay, just a couple threads. As
Hassan get Oh, I actually I legitimately don't think Okay,
it's going to sound schizophrenic. I legitimately don't think
this started from an anti like an Israel related thing. I legitimately
think this starts with um I think this starts with like Destiny's
hatred for Hassan and just needing to like make him the bad guy
for his audience and then his audience who were you know
had a lot of streamers came up under him a lot of streamers he
influenced
I think those people went on to really hate Hassan as well but
I I do think it's honestly to honest to God I think it's mostly
the Hassan is bad element more than Israel even way more than
Israel I think there I would believe more that the Israel position
that some people are holding, especially streamers, has way more
to do with Han is bad than an actual, you know, informed position
on Israel.
Hold on, let me go. There's a substance on this. Give me a second.
He pulled this up like last night.
Where was this? Where was this? Where was this? The 2019 logs.
Where are these at? Let me find the substance.
>> Right here. Is this one, man? >> 19 logs when
he was jealous of you.
Yeah, this is um >> reading some logs from this sad state
of affairs, but that's pretty irritating to hear like when all
these articles are just getting written. People like Assan are
creating a safer space on Twitch. Lol. I've done this for the
past 3, four years on my own. This is by the way from 2019. This
is like this is the real truth nuke as to why him and his community
have been obsessed
since 2019.
Oh, is that too loud for you guys? I Hold on. Let me see how
this looks when it's at 100. Sounded quiet to me. >> I
don't get a salary from some company or some support from investigators
or some type. I've done all this work on my own for so long.
The idea that someone coming into the safe space that I've created
almost on my own because of my relentless presence on all these
shows and then try to accuse me of not belonging here. Law seems
pretty. Do you see why though? I knew this was always going to
happen this way. Do you know how frustrating it is? has been
over the past year watching people in my fan base bleed over
to Hassan because we share the same conclusions even though I
knew the entire time. We're fundamentally different. If you want
to know where his villain arc started where he
it's just so funny man. I'm sorry.
Like it's just so transparent.
I had to watch people bleed over to this guy for a whole year.
Do you think he created separation just knowing like is is clavvicular
just like the true sage of the internet
actually if somebody just copies your positions all of them and
they're better looking than you then you have to switch positions
you can't occupy that space anymore is that what happened here
is Hassan just came in came in as the look maxer he's just totally
looks maxed and Destiny had to switch his positions up entirely
is that what happened
do I have to apologize to >> where he literally went from
like being a Bernie bro social democrat. >> Did Hassan
just come in and mob >> that kind of guy who used to say
things like Israel is an aparttheite state to basically warping
his entire worldview and flipping the script on it and like repositioning
himself as this like rabid neoliberal
who
uh raid neoliberal who who hates the left almost more than he
hates the right seemingly. Uh this is the reason. It's all spite.
I don't think it's appropriate to say uh everyone's politics
are spitebased on the internet, but if there's one person who
is uh legitimately spitebased
and only takes the oppositional uh point no matter what, it's
this.
Mike said that his true anger for you stems from him losing access
to your female audience for purposes. He's not angry about the
ideology, but Matt, he can't predate on your audience when the
friendship ended.
That could be part of the reason. I don't know. But
um but yeah, he went from like every single thing that he has
said
before 2019.
Uh he has he has basically gone,
man, I'm about to make a tweet and I feel I just feel really
bad because this is I'm cribing this entirely from Top Bronson.
I took this from Top Bronson entirely, but it is awesome.
I feel bad because I I tried to collab with Legal Mindset once
when I was covering the Destiny documents and he he was nice
about it. He was like, "Oh, you know, I'm not doing it yet, but
maybe I'll talk to you like sometime later." He was nice about
it. So, I do feel a little bad tweeting at him in that way. Just
it feels like it could be seen as snaky, but I think I pretty,
you know, objectively evaluated this guy's content. I think I
can kind of I can go after Okay, I can do it. Yeah, we can do
Sorry. We've got, you know, AI is great for some things. Okay.
AI is very good for some things. I know some people aren't fans,
but that's just fantastic stuff. Okay, that's just fantastic
stuff. If you don't like that tweet, then I don't know what to
tell you, man. I don't know what to tell you. There it is right
there. Okay, we're coming for legal mindsets next. All right,
he's the next to fall.
Budang is letting you know
your time is up. Your time is up. Okay,
your time is up. Legal mindset.
Tick- tock. Legal mindset. Tick- tock.
Tick
tock.
I'm never late.
Anyway, keep going. Where's this? >> It's owned by legal
mindset. This video is such a good vid. Watch defo recommended.
Legal mindset. Hassan [__] is one of the people on
the internet that is the most comfortable using slander and defamation.
He's lucky no one has sued.
In another video, Legal Mindset also called out and explained
why Hassan is a pseudointellectual who speaks deeply on topics
he has no idea about. I don't love Legal Mindset. EDB and always
been my man primary law tubers. Legal mindset on YouTube with
the slam dunk.
Legal mindset tortes us for dumb takes on the Ethan,
>> not the H3H3 lawsuit. Pseudo intellectuals like Assan
use big words that do not understand. How do these guys get popular?
You need to understand there are a lot of charlatan scumbags.
charlatan scumbags.
>> Scarletton, eh? >> Scarletton schumbags.
There are a lot of charlatan scumbags on the internet who are
just manic, who are just insane, who just run around and and
uh spread as much toxicity as they possibly can. There's so many
more. Eventually, they started to catch on and said, "Ess careful
with this guy." E fans posted kawaii edits of this racist piece
of [__] By the way, Mr. Andrew is Esquire. >> By
the way, just pointing out remember
who certain people backed and when Pisco came out and said, "Oh,
these guys are these this lawyer."
Don't forget Pisco is also saying this guy's content was stupid.
And some people were like, "Oh, no, Pisco, you're wrong. You're
wrong. Actually, are you even a lawyer, Pisco?"
So, there's a there's a Pisco W. >> I'm reading a song
to absolute filth, but with a smile. It's petty gorly summer.
I don't know how to edit. I've se I have severe ADHD. It's contagious.
my condolences. That's why I always say, "Judge me by my enemies."
Okay? They're just malicious. They're just vindictive. They just
want to dish out what they have done to themselves, refusing
to acknowledge why they're personally consistently taking L after
L.
>> Door's open.
They are just angry, resentful, narcissistic little monsters.
And they will align with every single person that they possibly
can as long as they're all united. Law the difference when they
finally did research. Legal mindset has completely lost his mind.
Legal mindset being weird on Maine in reference to legal mindset.
>> yeah. I guess seven months ago something changed cuz
they were loving legal
>> It was that white women stalking thing. That's what
>> And then seven months ago they were like, "Okay, this
guy might be a right-wing psychopath." They're just straight
up evil, brother. That's it.
Okay. They're just straight up evil.
Not the audiences. The audiences are just duped. Okay.
Yeah. Here. Techone. Hassan dug up past crimes of Teone's dad
in order to weaponize Tech's past trauma with his dad against
him as retaliation.
I do love that Hassan's just running with this to defend himself.
It is very
>> Teone wishes the fam well.
The allegations of being >> Who was that? Nine months ago.
Nine months ago.
Oh. Uhoh. >> Tech wishes the fam well with charges for
but it doesn't even matter. >> Nah. Nah. Nah.
>> Are we almost done with all the Teone content for today?
I want to do more Teetone content. But if we don't have more
reactions, we don't have anything else from around the internet.
Then I think it's time for us to move on. We'll have to see.
Hold on. I'm trying to see. What are we looking at? There was
an XQC reaction to Chud that we could take a look at.
Oh, wait. We got a we Oh, we got a miskf statement. Hold on.
We apparently have a misk statement on the techone stuff. Give
me a second. Give me just a second.
Let's see this. This is from a little while ago. All right. >> Committed
of a crime. You're right. You weren't committed of a crime.
>> Teone says, "I wasn't committed of a crime." You're
right. You weren't committed of a crime, but you are downplaying
what you are so badly. Teone is trying to make it seem like the
Techone went to court because Teetone and and uh Pinkchu had
a resolve over, you know, fines and and and some civil court
that doesn't matter.
Civil court doesn't matter for some things. You're right. Civil
court can be anything. But you were on the such the hard end
of civil court that if you didn't delete what you had in your
phone that day, you were going to be charged with criminal contempt
of what you had in that phone. You weren't just con you weren't
just convicted of so it weren't just preceded >> techto
you had disgusting things in your phone to that day. Do you know
how crazy that is chat to say that he had stuff about Pinkchu
when they broke up like two years ago still in his phone of them
with non-consensual
and non-consensual things. Do you know >> I here's the
thing I know Miz is saying that.
I think if that were all truly decided, Teetone would have criminal
charges. So, like I I understand that's probably like an allegation
or something and perhaps he deleted some things that he would
allege are consensually recorded. I don't know. I think if that
was all proven out quite so strongly, I do believe um I do believe
he would probably have criminal charges. It wouldn't be like,
"Hey, we're going to threaten you with criminal charges." It
would be like, "Yeah, you're going to you're going to jail, buddy.
You're going to jail, buddy."
Oh, god. Somebody made the roach the roach one. We got an Asthma
Gold one as
>> Very cool. Very, very cool.
>> crazy it is that he had to delete it that day. That
he still had things in his phone. You didn't delete it before
after all the times you and Pinch you had arguments about it.
You never deleted it before. You never deleted
>> That's not what he's saying though. Hold on. That's
not what he's saying. Canadian caller. He's saying that there
would be criminal >> say that he had stuff about Pinkchu
when they broke up like two victed of court that if you didn't
delete what you had in your phone that day, you were going to
be charged with criminal contempt of what you had in that phone.
>> Criminal, you're going to be charged with criminal contempt.
>> You weren't just con you weren't just convicted of sexual
assault. You weren't just proceeded, Tone. You had
>> I think that's
>> you weren't just forced >> convicted of assault.
You weren't just forced tech.
>> You had disgusting things in your phone to that day.
Do you know how crazy that is chat to say that he had stuff about
Pink Chew when they broke up? Like >> Miz is not illiterate.
He read the documents fantastically >> two years ago still
in his phone of them with non-consensual
and non-consensual things. Do you know how crazy it is that he
had to delete it that day? That he still had things in his phone.
You didn't delete it before after all the times you and Pinch
you had arguments about it. You never deleted it before. You
never deleted after you guys broke up. You guys, you held on
to that.
>> So, it sounds like this along with the um the order
that was there at the end that Te was probably trying to allege,
no, all these videos are consensual, right? She was saying they
were non-consensual and the judge probably said, "Hey, delete
all of that and if I ever find out that you shared anything about
her, like it's over for you." I'm guessing that's what it is.
And I'm guessing this is all downstream of what I assume, but
we don't know for sure. what I assume is like uh a threat that's
been documented a threat to publish revenge whatever that's been
documented because otherwise I don't know why they would add
into the the uh [__] I don't know why they would
add into the protective order the idea that he can never publish
send any photos or videos of Pinkchu for the entirety of the
the uh duration the entirety of the protective order right
they added that in custom for him I'm guessing that has to do
with uh with him making the threat like credibly recorded making
the threat either voice or through text.
>> You held on to that tech tone. That's disgusting, man.
It's disgusting.
I wasn't involved in criminal proceedings. No, I'm not going
to jail or facing any criminal punishment. We will wait and see
on that one because we all know damn well that you are going
to probably spill the beans at one point and ruin your protective
order. And that's what this guy's doing. He is trying to downplay
this so hard.
Like he Where does he mention he's got a protective order? Where
do you mention that you have a protective order? Where do you
mention any of this stuff? No, you don't. He doesn't want to.
>> Well, he literally can't. I think he literally I think
him talking about the protective order, I do think that's like
actually
I I don't think he can make a statement about like almost all
of it. I think he's basically totally barred from talking about
this or drawing attention to it on the internet. I think he I
think he actually is told like don't talk about it.
>> Yeah, we covered the new cards >> because he knows
it makes him sound bad. So, he just says the things that make
him look good. Tech
>> I
I He is doing that. I do think like litigating parts of the civil
stuff is not something he could do. Trying to goat him though.
Maybe. Maybe. And that could be funny. Yes, he's just trying
to goat him into doing it. It could be very
Tone says, "I wasn't committed of a crime." You're right. You
weren't committed of a crime. >> Oh boy. Oh boy.
All right. What else do we got here on this stuff from today?
What else do we got? I'm looking around. Are we doing more techone
stuff today?
Difficult to say for sure. Wait, is Miz not blocked by him? Miz
has to be blocked, right? Yeah. M.
>> GG. Okay. I'm I'm looking for anything. I'm looking
for any scraps I can on on stuff on this. Okay. where the guy
is just a sick freak
[__] disgusting pervert. Okay, >> I'm good.
Thank you. >> And you can keep coping and keep putting
your little posts and you can go and self soothe
and you can go and self soo and you can watch legal cover this
and tell you everything's going to be okay.
>> This is
damning, right? >> And I would wager, >> dude. with
a little bit little bit of digging, a little bit of looking about
>> and so on. Okay,
it's only going to get worse.
Only going to get worse. More egregious. Apparently Henry's got
some more details he's going to be putting out there.
>> Oh [__] Do we have more details?
And that's
>> roast. Do we have more details in the Henry Resilient
stuff is the Henry Resilient video. Do we have more details >> That's
it. and we'll get to it. But it seems like some people just don't
really have an appetite for talking about this, which is insane
to me. >> People will bring up a Google doc of the most
nothing allegations ever and go to town on it. Okay, W. Peach
Jars W. Peach Jars,
uh, Teone, he Teone has me blocked on every account, but can't
y'all post this under Te's latest tweet or sorry, can y'all post
this under Tetoone's latest tweet? And please ask him if he's
jealous. Thank you. I don't know if you guys remember this, but
Peach Stars had a whole thing where she was on TechOne a couple
months ago and basically calling out other people for sweeping
and not on this guy. Not even on the stuff, which is bad, but
just on the right-wing pivot on like the grift, the clear grift
he was doing, right? Hey, why why aren't we all calling this
out? Hey, Techone, the reason people don't like you isn't because
of the stuff. They could let that go. It's actually because you're
a totally fake furler. Okay, that's what Peach Stars was saying.
I personally wouldn't say that word, but peach stars, she loves
dropping that, especially when it's in regards to Tectone. Okay,
very concerning. Not very woke, not very, you know, progressive,
but
accurate. Really, just accurate. I don't know if you guys have ever
heard Teeone tell that story about how he could feel the beard
on the other guy he was making out with, but gross. Okay. Gross.
Yuck. Yuck. Did we even finish this chug clip or did I talk through
it? Did I just yap through it? I just yapped through it. Closing
some tabs. Closing some tabs. Closing some tabs. Closing some
tabs. a legal document. You've got Pinkchu making claims to a
court in order to justify getting a protective order that potentially
takes this guy's guns away. And apparently that's now been concluded
and people don't want to touch it.
Why not? This is like, you know, it's horrific certainly, but
in terms of like a drama perspective, this
>> Sorry, not to again, but this was the clip. Okay, >> I
said what we were all thinking. That was it. That was generally
it. >> Oh, hold on. Hold on. Did I not pull the I pulled
the tweet, too, right? Where my tweet at? Where my tweet at?
Uhoh.
Yes.
I love my colleagues that respect me. Is a part of the Peach
Star stuff. Oh, it's the same clip though. Okay. Okay. Okay.
Hold on. She called him out on Twitter. We'll just read the the
tweet off of her. So, he says, "Good night, boys. Today was a
rough one. Praying for at least one good day for all of us tomorrow."
I think this is about No, it's not about Charlie. I pray you
shut the [__] up is what Pete Char tweeted at him.
Okay, >> I said what we were all thinking. That was it.
That was genuinely it. This wasn't me coming out with this massive
political statement. It wasn't. And genuinely like I know he's
probably going to break some down or not because he's probably
like, I don't want to give her attention. Blah blah blah blah
blah. I don't care. But dude, you were genuinely so chill and
I
know you're just grifting. I'm sorry. And I just know from the
bottom of the heart, you just can't sit there like your audience
is going to believe you and that's fine. Whatever. I do think
you guys have a lower IQ. Genuinely, I'm sorry. I feel that way.
>> So true. Yes. All Techone fans have a low IQ. Prerequisite
for joining the fandom. Absolutely true. Peach, thank you. Continue
to cook. >> But your heart's not in it, and I don't know
what the happened. And that's genuinely it.
genuinely yet there is nothing crazy to say about that look and
then people are like you're not speaking about this situation
that situation
this is something the techone situation
has been going on in my life my friend circle for well over a
year year and a half where
>> oh by the way like I know other people in Austin I've
got a couple other people I know in Austin through like streamers
or friends of friends who do know like other stuff who've heard
like rumors about techone It's all bad, man. It's all bad. >> I've
been like, >> "Will JC do the pinky chew it with but with
Peach SHs or is he actually just kink posting every time?" Does
Peach Stars do content? I feel like it'd be weird if she didn't
publish. >> [__] is going on? What is going
on? And
I just got to my breaking point, okay? Is that a lot of people
want me to speak on people that I hang out with or I know. But
the thing is, you guys want me to sit on live stream fails and
do research about everybody I know and make exact statements.
These are real people that I experience daytoday life with.
I have been mulling on this for years to just tell him to shut
the [__] up. This is not my usual content.
I think he's dumb. I think he's homophobic.
And did I mention dumb?
That's it. >> Self-hating. Self-hating homophobe. self-hating.
Obviously, >> yes. Yes. Because I I deal with the I mean,
yes, I heard about several years about him being a piece of [__]
but that's what I mean is that it was so confusing. It was a
genuine like, what the is going on? I don't understand.
>> So, we're just looking for context, guys. We're just
getting context on this tweet why she said, "Please post this
under Tet."
She got in a fight with Te with with Teetone. Got a little harassment
from his community, a little hate from his community. And >> that
is it. >> Not a fan. All right.
>> That is it. And for a while,
I'm invited to events where I'm not 100% sure of everybody I'm
doing events with. Okay, there's some people that I like more
and there's some people I don't like as much. And at these streamer
events, not everybody is holding hands and getting along and
skipping around. But if you want to be relevant and you want
to have a job, you show up to the events and you smile at the
camera and you wave hello. Okay,
that's how it is. And regardless of how you feel about it until
the end of time, it's always going to be like that. It is always
going to be like that. Obviously, now if I have strong opinions
on somebody, I probably wouldn't show up to events. I probably
wouldn't.
Wow. No, actually I have. There have been events I don't show
up to because I'm like that is close proximity to people I don't
get along with.
Anyway, we were just looking for the reasoning for the tweet.
We got it now.
I do think this is awesome.
I will retweet this actually.
She was calling him out when this was like, by the way, this
is not like small. It seems like it doesn't matter at all, but
she's like not that big a streamer. And she did kind of call
him out when he was at like his height. Like I want to say he
was at the biggest he got doing his grifting and she called him
out like the very height of it. So, it's not exactly nothing.
It's not like she made a huge sacrifice. She's not Jod Varc or
anything, but it wasn't nothing to go and like sort of inject
herself in a way where she thought this guy was doing something
wrong and she spoke up.
I actually don't think it's like as
irrelevant or unimportant as some people would say. Some people
would say, "Oh, it doesn't like matter." Right. That was in the
past. Yeah, that whole clip that is from I think I pulled that
off LSF, right? Let's see when that was
three months ago.
So it was before like the pinky stuff was blowing up and Tectton
was big and I think it was right as he retired. Yeah, it was
a month after he started going to just the YouTube videos and
he started tweeting a lot more. He was like getting bigger on
Twitter. He was doing his like heavy tweeting arc and she's like,
"Dude, just shut the up." It's like it's not massive. It's just
not nothing.
I appreciate it, you know.
I appreciate.
Y the mighty clean your ears out. What the hell? I just said
we covered it. I just said yes. I covered the Lucari stuff. Yeah,
he's lying. He's lying. He's lying. He's lying. He's lying. He's
lying. He's lying. He's lying. He's lying. He's lying because
I literally click into this and look at my reply and it's like,
"Bro, why'd you have like a thing? Why' you download? That has
nothing to do with there's no there's no like Japanese tag for
there's no tag for that's not the way that works, right? Why
do you have the thing you could say?" Hey, so Lucari is trying
to say here, I'm only interested in 2D stuff.
Lie, lie, lie, lie, lie, lie. Chibi reviews sweeping for tee.
You got links. Chibi, you got links brain. I'd check it out.
Is Chibi Review still going? There's no way he's still going.
I remember the original sweep against Miskf. But
is it all Is it just Hold on. There's no way it's just these
guys over and over again, right? Hold on. Oh, let's see. Oh,
man. More sweepers. Let's go, guys. Real quick, this is the original
Techone tweet. He's saying he's not a a crime, wasn't a criminal
proceeding, he's not going to jail.
Was watching Legal Mindset's video on this, and he covered it
very well. No, he didn't. By the way, 80% of the content of Legal
Mindset's video is him covering the frame Pinky Choose civil
case, which is essentially unrelated to this case, right?
That's it. It's essentially unrelated. It's so stupid. We watch
this. I don't even know if Legal Mindset realized that these
cases were unrelated. Somebody asked him in the middle of the
clip and I don't know if they know or not, but it's like
he actually covers a totally unrelated civil case where the plaintiff
in that civil case civil case, sorry. The person who filed the
civil case, Pikachu, actually withdrew it. So, I don't know why
you take the complaint in a case where it was withdrawn and say
this is all relevant evidence, but also not look almost entirely
at the Pinky Tree documents. It's actually crazy, man. Oh, we
pulled this up earlier, the the getting hacked stuff. We we talked
about this stuff. But guys, remember Johnny Depp, dude, it's
it's G. It's it's crazy that he did that video and then it was
just it was bad, man. It was really bad watching the whole thing.
It was it was rough. Okay, so he says he's watching the legal
mindset video. Even Legal Mindset agrees that what happened makes
him sympathetic to you. You aren't a convicted criminal and you
will not be going to jail. A most of the content of the
legal mindset video is with respect to a different civil case.
is not involved in the protective order
case that was just resolved.
Dream Tech's ex-wife. God. Okay.
Right now, I'm not convinced you are evil or a vile guy after
seeing the files reviewed. Even Pinky Chu in the files said you
weren't a groomer, which legal mindset pointed out. Overall,
I reformatted I reformatted my earlier comment to better outline
my thoughts to give better insight. People want a villain and
will look at clip notes
clip notes to form an opinion instead of reading the full files.
You haven't read the full files. You haven't read legal mindset
didn't read. It's actually crazy, dude. Okay, somebody responds
to this. Keep sucking up to the guy who wants to see you behind
bars from what you uh for what you like. I'm sure he'll see you
as one of the good ones and spare you. You lack suck a backbone.
It's insane. Such a backbone. Is this techone?
Okay. Oh, the he's getting pressure. This is like getting pressured
from the left wing as like a sock dem. Okay. This is like getting
pressured by socialist is a sock dem or a democratic socialist.
Okay. But it's like getting he's getting pressured from the contingent.
Okay. the super pro openly pro contingent.
This guy thinks you're a Why? Why don't you defend this? This
guy would put you in jail. This guy wants to take away your freedom
to consume drawn images of children having this guy wants to
take it away from you. It's like, okay, what? Wait, what?
The lack of backbone is apparently looking at the full evidence
of the files and seeing he hasn't been convicted as a criminal.
This is a bunch of he said, she said going on within it, too.
Sorry, this Yeah, he's literally typing. will just be your pay.
>> Hello ZM Punk donated $25.
>> Oh, let's go. Uh, thank you so much, ZM Punk. Appreciate
it, man.
Thank you. Thank you. No donation message. Those are the best
ones. Thank you so much, man. Appreciate it. Civil courts work
extremely differently. Truthfully, he needs to appeal and take
it to a higher court. As for him wanting me behind bars, Teone
has clearly changed and has been nothing but kind to me since
I met
I like to wait until there's undeniable evidence someone did
a crime. I don't like he said, she said stuff.
Why do you think civil courts are he said, she said?
It's not. It's them looking at the the preponderance of evidence
and coming to a conclusion. It's not he said, she said. They
they take evidence into
Maybe you should wonder why TeeOne could produce no evidence
showing that he wasn't doing the things that were alleged. You
should maybe wonder why TeeOne could produce no evidence at all.
Right. And I'm not even talking about like the the sexual assault
stuff because I'm not sure how much they litigated that. But
it seems like they're pretty convinced he was stalking her. They're
pretty convinced he was harassing her. Why could Teto not like
pull anything out to say that's why I did this is why I didn't
do it. Why couldn't he explain his actions at all? Hold on. I
need to go and look at some other stuff. Bro, these people suck,
man. All these people suck. I need to grab this tweet and reput
it in the chat. You guys need to go juice this tweet. Okay. Oh,
I never put it in the chat yet, but you guys need to juice this
week. This one's important. Chippy reviews. Chibby reviews. Chippy
reviews. Chippy reviews. This guy sucks.
We will do actual content on this guy very soon. Trust me. This
guy just scammed a GoFundMe. I'm hearing. That's what I'm hearing.
But I will I will say it's an allegation. There are allegations
that this guy just scammed a GoFundMe. And we're going to look
into it. Okay. We will be looking into you, sir.
We'll be looking into you. What is this?
Okay, cap sign, but he's a villain. A Genchin Impact YouTube
channel completely dedicated to pandering to
the comments on the vids are just as bad as the content itself.
It actually makes me disgusted to have this type of content on
YouTube and even worse, people turning a blind eye and even worse
supporting it. He's not hurting anyone. If you're attracted to
Cle or someone of that body type,
you're probably going to end up hurting someone. No way in is
normalizing that behavior a good idea. context in my video that's
from December 31st, 2023. Very curious because we also have these
other we also have these other comments from Tactone about Cle
or Kimon or other underage characters >> himself has a
history of liking
that went as low as six to eight years old while ranking them
in a waifu tier >> Next up, Palon. Dude, I feel like if
Palon were to visit me, I feel like we'd just be best friends,
you know? And I bet she would taste delicious.
Imagine how Pimon's feet would taste when she's 18. Probably
like cinnamon and honey. Uh, should be fine. B for I can't believe
she's not butter. Awful. Chi-chi S tier. Adorable. Okay.
By the way, this is a waifu tier list. Just so we're clear. This
is a waifu tier list. As in girls I'd like to wipe up, girls
I'd like to be with. This is a waifu tier list. Just to make
it clear why this is weird. All right. It's a white food. >> Chi
S tier. Adorable. Okay. Hilarious. Cute. Get this girl a cocoa
goat. Okay.
is adorable. She is beautiful. Dude, this girl is already running
a hotel at like age six. IN PATCH 2.0, You know, when we gather
the Dragon Balls and we revive Chi-Chi and then she gets to expand
to level 18 and age 18. Imagine how amazing she would be. >> Cons
because
>> Wow. Wow. Wow. I like how he said level 18 and then
he had to correct to age 18.
I am I am I just weird that I don't see like drawn images of
six-year-olds and I'm like, man, I really wish she was 18 right
now. I'm like the o I I can't be the only one who's just never
had that thought before. I just never once thought that my entire
life. I can't imagine thinking it. I don't have the like I don't
have that part in the brain that lets me think that. I just I've
never thought that. That's a very weird thing to think for any
reason.
Hey, this six-year-old Oh man, what if she was 18? Very very
very very very
Uh, so that is in response to apparently this this comment he
made in December of 2023, which was anybody normalizing being
attracted to these underage body types, these underage girls,
is probably going to end up hurting someone. Sort of precient
when you think about it. No, knowing that in 2024 is when he
assaulted Pikachu. HE WAS RIGHT. HE DID actually end up hurting
somebody. Wow.
Tone is like Cassandra. Okay.
He saw it. He predicted it. And he couldn't stop himself from
doing it. Crazy
wild wild stuff. Okay.
Uh
I'll repost this to make my stance clear. Civil courts are very
different in how they handle are handled with evidence.
Civil courts are handled the way that the court of public opinion
is, right? In that the thing that is most likely like you could
evaluate all the evidence and make an argument and then it's
a little different. Sorry. It's basically the way you would handle
it is what do you think is more likely than not, right? That's
how civil courts work. But they have a judge who is equipped
to handle evidence knows what knows what is relevant to each
statute and they interpret the evidence such as it's given to
them and then they make a determination.
The determination here is that they found it reasonable to suspect
that it's likely or sorry they found it reasonable to say that
it's likely Teone did salter. Is that the language? I'll just
go to my own tweet. I don't want to I don't want to misspeak
on this one. Okay, hold on. Let me go to my own tweet real quick.
Court finds there are reasonable grounds to believe Teto both
insulted and stalked Pinky Chu. Thank you. Thank you. Oh, wise
one.
Yes.
All right. What else do we got here?
Not seeing anything else just yet.
Still looking. still looking.
There might actually be more of the Chibi Review stuff. Oh, and
the Tactical Templar video. We do need to go to that. Hold on.
Chibi Reviews. Go here and then I'm going to pull up Tactical
Templars's YouTube and we'll take a look at his live stream.
Tactical Templar.
You did a live stream today. Is that up right now? Don't be members
only. Nice. It just ended.
Better past for supporting the channel. >> Some of my bias
is toward God be like, "Oh, God.
>> Thank you for Thank you for finding this deal." But
>> the legal mindset stuff. >> There's something
so beautiful about the childlike innocence of somebody that doesn't
doesn't care one bit
about
perceptions.
Doesn't care what you
>> Well, some something beautiful about the childlike innocence.
I'm sorry given that this given this guy's like long past that
just immediately weirded me out. This guy is a big fan. All right.
TB Reviews is saying he is repressed and quote tweeting.
Is he like losing his own fan base? Is that is he like freaking
out and losing his own fan base right now?
No shot. No shot. No shot. No shot. No shot. Is this guy okay?
Depressed. Oh, depressed. Yeah, it's gross. Yeah, it's gross.
Yeah, it's gross. It's gross. It's gross. It's gross. It's gross.
>> Yeah. Enough. >> They only care about their relationship
with God and they want to give >> Okay, hold on, hold on,
hold on. We got him going over some miskiss stuff here. >> Yours
truly on this meme.
And uh apparently this >> uh if you guys are unaware, this
is Tactical Templar. He is Tee's spiritual adviser. He is the
guy who brought Tecton into the church into the Orthodox church.
All right. >> This person is supported by people.
weird, but >> who is a lull cow and a complete and total
joke. So, I don't know. I don't know what to make of this guy,
but I did think this was very interesting. Multiple people reached
out and said, "Hey, this guy reacted to it to you." Um, so without
further ado, ladies and gentlemen, we're going to be watching
this segment of yours truly on this this video, which has 43,000
views.
That's a lot of views. Anyway, let's uh take a look. Throw away
tweets out this clip with the caption tech. >> Oh, Twitter
versus >> best friend at Tactical Templar smears
>> Tactical Templar reviewing his own Twitter versus segment.
Very cool. Oh, we've got the uh the the Henry Resilient Tech.
Okay. >> Do we get Do we get any other video from Henry
Resilient here? He stream or something about this? He did. He's
streaming. Okay. Okay. >> This is Techto.
>> We might check this out. We'll see if Henry's got anything
new for us.
>> Tactical Templar. I'm his best friend now. Now, let
me just set the record straight. I would love
to come on here and and stroke my own ego, guys. Yeah, Techone
and I, we're besties.
We're
Let me let me just lay it on the truth. All right.
I reach out to Techone if he and I let him know if he needs support,
if he needs Bible verses, anything like that.
I'm here for and he knows that. But we don't communicate.
>> Listen, brother. Listen, brother.
I don't know if you could get a miracle, but you need a miracle.
We don't have 10,000 viewers on Twitter. We have like We had
like 60 viewers on Twitter or something. That's the total views
of >> that number. So, you know, >> the guy's busy.
The guy's got his own life to live. But this idea that him and
I are like best friends.
We're buddies.
Like Teone, Asminold and I, we all we all do like the meme. We
all like walk around. No,
Asminold doesn't know who I am.
Teone and I are I would say friendly.
I told Teone I got his back because I haven't seen anything
from the files thus far
that are uh that are what people are
>> But if it were revealed that Teone
actually
uh did something as despicable as People always say this, oh,
if we find out that he like actually did the thing, you understand
that like for a
closed room, unless somebody is illegally recording it, you're
never going to get proof ever. You're never going to get like
proof positive. You're never going to have proof beyond a shadow
of a doubt. So just say you don't believe in sexual assault.
You don't believe in prosecuting assault cases. Just say that
you don't believe in like any unless somebody, you know, records
the video. You don't believe in prosecuting these cases. Just
say that. Okay. Don't do this sweep like we all, you know, just
want to hang this guy for no reason. It's so dumb, man. >> You
know, force himself on a girl. I would absolutely criticize him.
>> I mean, there's no there's no question about that. But
I haven't seen anything like that. >> If you want me to
criticize Teone, show me a video of him raping. Why don't Why
don't you have a video of Techone raping?
If Why do you call him rapetone? And you don't even have a video
of him raping me. I wouldn't call somebody rapetone if if I didn't
have a video of them raping. Come on, man. >> It It seems
to me like, as is mostly with the internet, that it's a lot of
sensationalism. It's a lot a lot of what aboutism, and it's a
lot of selective outrage. If you want me to be honest,
>> there's no way that
Takia Templar, fan of marital, could possibly be talking about
what aboutism when his entire first commentary on this is, uh,
what are we supposed to trust, Msk? What are we supposed to trust?
Msk. What? Am I supposed to trust mis? Okay, that's the definition
of what aboutism, bro. >> Why on earth are we talking about
You've got >> um, what about Msk and Emir? What about Msk
and Emiru? Sorry, that's more the definition of what aboutism.
What about Misk and Emiru? Have you heard about Misk and Emiru?
Don't pay attention to this. What about Miskanu that's still
on the internet making content?
Why are >> I like that everybody's
Dude, there's no way. Hold on, let me back it up. I do think
it's very funny. >> It seems >> that everybody's
like worst example of a predator who still makes comment internet
commentary like one person. >> Like as is mostly with the
internet that it's a lot of sensationalism. It's a lot a lot
of what aboutism and it's a lot of selective outrage. If you
want me to be honest, why on earth are we talking about techone?
You've got Destiny that's still on the internet making content.
Why on earth are you >> every time, right? >> Talking
about techone when Destiny has
far worse
if it's not about if it's actually about
guys. We hate what aboutism by the way. We hate what aboutism.
THERE'S NO NO WORSE CRIME THAN WHAT ABOUTISM. ALSO, what about
destiny? >> The action itself and the morality of >> You
will have to explain to me why somebody like Destiny and even
somebody like Hassan can do what they do. By the way, if you
don't know where Hassan falls into this, I could bring up the
clip of uh QT Cinderella admitting that Hassan assaulted her,
that Han walked out and basically showed him uh her
her um showed her his
Yeah. Uh Lwig's girlfriend admitted that on stream. I did a video
on it. The video is not going away. She actually said that on
stream that his son walked out there in these super tight shorts
and you know basically the implication was that he uh basically
just let it all out. So these people do this sort of hideous
heinous evil and people go yeah they're bad but you know they
have the right politics for me. It's not about the action. It's
about how much you don't like the person. That's really all it's
about, which makes it that much more pathetic.
It makes it that much more pathetic.
>> he's not allowed to own any firearms or weapons. Techone
is not any allowed anywhere near her.
>> That's It is. We all know that. That is true. That's
madness.
He can't own a gun. Are you >> true? On on a civil case.
A civil case, he can't own a gun. That is that is a violation
of the second
>> I mean the I have to remind you guys
>> I have to remind you
the burden of proof in a civil case I I have to I have to tell
you guys. >> Is he about to Is he about to say the most
thing we've ever heard in our entire lives? The burden of proof
in a civil case if he means the standard of evidence the the
standard of proof is
uh preponderance of evidence. is that if that's what he's going
to say, that's not so bad. If he's about to say the burden of
proof is like on the accused or something to prove that this
happened or didn't happen, it's not true. That's not true. That's
not it.
I I have to I have to tell you guys
the burden of proof.
We're going to go over this.
The burden of proof in a civil case.
See uh purpose uh who brings the case burden of proof uh beyond
in beyond a reasonable doubt. Preponderance of the evidence.
These two things are very very
>> Very high standard. Jury must be almost certain of guilt.
>> So you're talking 99.9%.
Preponderance of evidence.
more likely than not, 50% probability.
So, you mean to tell me that while he wasn't charged criminally,
he was charged civily where the burden of proof is so unbelievably
lower and then that is ultimately what lost him his right to
own a gun. That is
Uh 8 to1 Rahini B USA or Rahini whatever Raheem. Okay.
8 to1 decision, my guy. 8 to1 decision. The most conservative
Supreme Court in US history disagrees with you. They say, "Hey,
if you're going to if you're going to be someone who's got a
protective order for assault, you can't have guns."
Okay. No, it's not absurd.
>> That is madness.
So, I stand by
>> So, Teone just lost a 50-50 coin flip. I don't think
he lost a 50-50 coin flip. I think he, you know, didn't didn't
bring very much evidence for his own side and had a mountain
of evidence on the other side and got kind of embarrassed in
court and we'll see what happens. But like I don't I don't think
it's not a coin flip, right? It's just like no, I think it's
reasonable. It's like likely that he did this.
That's the exact same way you'd make a decision, right? >> Every
word that I said there, >> in fact, I'm I'm going to double
down on
Like
this is just some typical
degenerate me too.
Now, if Tekt were guilty, I would be the first one to call him
out.
But we've seen what type of eth garbage tier lying bimbo
Pinky Chu is. >> We've seen the type of person they are.
We've seen the type of people this person runs with. Uh, no,
I don't believe this for a single second.
with how broken our court system is, with how they have this
prop.
>> So absolutely crazy thing to say. Okay,
I have so I have less outrage when his tactical templar doing
it than the the other guy, the Braxton guy, because this guy's
like a total degenerate who hates women. Like I expect it when
I watch this guy, right? This guy's a total degenerate who hates
women. He's never going to have anybody in his life. He's like
a totally lost cause. Okay.
So, with this guy, I get less upset, but it is gross. All of
the things he says >> to simp for these.
Absolutely not. Ridiculous.
But if she actually felt that she was um that he committed a
crime, why didn't she go to the police?
Why didn't why wasn't this guy charged
>> She literally went to the police, >> which he
should have been. If if tech >> incredibly difficult to
re he the the slide he just showed is why the police might have
said it's entirely possible the police went hey like this sucks
but we can't prosecute this because of the high burden of proof
in a criminal court it would actually be a waste of resources
to prosecute this. They will tell you that sometimes, right?
If it's just like a he said, she said, there's no real contemporaneous
evidence. It's like very difficult to to ascertain like what
did or didn't happen beyond a reasonable doubt.
They'll tell you like we're the the prosecutor could decline
very easily to to prosecute the case. It could happen.
Luckily, we had the civil court system to pick up the slack.
Tone assaulted a
Why didn't she go to the Why didn't she go to the cops? Because
it didn't
Yeah, this whole uh you know preponderance of the evidence. So
basically it just has to be like 51%.
That's why >> you cover Asagold calling destiny a rword.
Yeah. >> Go civil. >> Yeah, I've got that on the
docket for later. We >> because there's a lower burden.
>> Oh, wait. Hold on. Vin, look at your How about you look
at your DMs, Vane? How about you look at your DMs and accept
the DM for B. And then I literally asked you about this. I was
like, hey, you watch this on you probably covered this. You probably
understand where all the links are. Show me the links. I'll cover
>> insane. And it's destroy somebody's reputation. And
the fact that he can't own guns
is disgusting. That is a violation of the Second Amendment.
I think that is uh I I think that's despicable. >> I frankly
I find this person disgusting. Okay. Their existence their existence
is disgusting to me. >> Base Templar.
>> Lazy streamer L. Okay. Liton. Would you like me to just
navigate through these things and figure out what the first tweet
is and do all that on stream? I could do that. It's very easy.
It's not difficult at all. I just didn't have time to do it and
it was developing while I was going live. So, there it is.
>> Absolutely. Base Templar. Yeah. >> Amro replies,
"Why didn't she go to the cops? What do you think she did, bro?"
Chud logic a quote we throw away by saying, "Tectone became friends
with this months ago for exactly this reason. So, he would blindly
defend him when legal proceedings didn't >> No. No, you
see the these people are retards. They don't have a brain and
they exist in this disgusting nebulous space on the internet.
No. If it turned out that TeeOne
if if in the court case it turned out that TeeOne
was abusive
and he he beat his girlfriend and he was somebody that was, you
know, constantly
insulting her, you know, all this stuff. >> Why' you have
to wait? Why do you have to just one one's free? Okay, first
one's free. If he was constantly assaulting her, though, that's
where the problem is. Wait, then where's his uh problem with
Miskf then? As far as I know, there's only one allegation of
that with Miskip. What What is his problem with Misk? If if the
requirement is if the bar is constant assault, you just be all
the time.
If that's the bar, what are we doing? Got a Hassan tweet. What's
the Hassan tweet? What's Hassan tweeting? What is this? Demanding
this lawbreaking murderous agency must follow the law is not
going to cut it. What must be cut are its funds. Why are you
linking me random? Dude, we're doing we're snarking on techone
right now. Why are you linking me political tweets? I thought
this was going to be him saying rape tone. Rape tone. Rape tone.
Rape tone. That's the tone. That's read the room. Jesus cow.
That's where we're at right now. Okay, we'll get to politics
stuff in a little bit, but this is Yes, this is snarking time.
Okay.
Toad is the tone of the stream. Okay.
Is that the real Hila? That was very >> No, I would. >> There's
some troll in his chat who was like saying they were Hila Klein
and they wanted to talk to him. Wait, no, hold on. That was stale.
Oh, we got to do the stale stuff, too. Man, there's so much good
content to come out. >> Absolutely. Call him out for that.
And I >> boot up Marvel Rivals right now. Uh, I was just
watching Steam. Okay, I was just watching Steam. I saw somebody
go live and boot up Marvel. Oh, no, not this. I saw somebody
go live and boot up Marvel Rivals.
Okay, I was watching Steam and I'm like
with him and yet still made me come to the house. [__]
I saw somebody go live. I got to do my job, okay? I have to actually
do my goddamn job.
>> that's disgusting behavior. And I tell him that he should
go to confessional and he should go to church and he should confess
that and he should work for years in order to try to rehabilitate
himself
and that he should be punished because his crime would be severe.
That would be my advice to Teeone.
But the problem is
that what these people are alleging, what these people are saying
is not accurate to the reality of the situation. And people like
this guy,
>> my my allegations are precisely accurate to the situation.
>> This freak >> bro. If you I would say you should
go to church. God help you, my friend. God help you. Would I
report it to the police? No. No.
I just pray. says Teto became friends with me for some benefit
to himself.
Teto doesn't need me.
What?
Like like Oh, Teto needs me so that I'll defend him.
Oh man,
that is that is a wild
Techone is a much bigger content creator than I am. Teone knows
content creators that are much bigger than I am.
Why would he need me?
This is just typical leftist brain content creation.
Tone doesn't need me.
I'm analyzing this the way that legal mindset would analyze it
or anyone else would. I'm looking at the situation and I'm making
a determination based on what I know about the guy and based
on what I know about the girl.
>> So, just his biases. I'm not going to read the court
documents. I'm not going to look into what was proposed for evidence,
what the witnesses were. I'm not going to look at any of that.
I'm just going to take what my thoughts are on only fans girls
and apply that to her. And then I'm going to take my undying
devotion to Teone. I'm going to apply that to him. And then I'm
going to come to a totally impartial determination that Teeone
didn't do nothing, guys. Teone didn't do nothing. Let him go.
He's a good boy. He didn't do anything. All right? And based
on what I know about the courts and basically all the things
that I know about the internet and what I know about culture
and what I know about the law and what I know about all this
stuff, I'm using it to make an informed opinion and I'm putting
it out there on the
Like Tech needs some guy that has less than 30,000 subs on YouTube
to to fight for him. No. And that's ridiculous.
you know, techone would be fine whether I was making content
or not, but I'm doing what I think is right. And that's something
these people cannot even fathom.
These people cannot fathom that.
I understand exactly why he's doing it. He's he literally just
laid it out. He's super biased. He hates women. He hates uh sex
workers specifically regardless of whether they post nudes or
have like hardcore content. He hates all people who would sell
any loot image of themselves there. Therefore, he hates Pinky
Chu, right? He's just laid it out for us precisely. He just hates
women. So, he's gonna side with Techone. I don't like I don't
have any outrage. Like, I I can fathom it. I understand why you're
doing it. I think everybody understands why you're doing it.
I just think it's weird and gross >> because they >> and
I'm gonna I'm gonna sit here in the most treacherous, disgusting,
amorphous, godless world
where these people, I mean, they each other in the back all the
time. They're they're exposed as degenerates every other day.
This guy, Internet Adjacent, the other day, he made a a video
about my channel and oh man, all the detractors were applauding
him.
Uh oh. Did he hear about internet adjacent with Parlo? Uh oh.
>> And then like a week later, turns out the guy was revealed
as a he was a gay furry and he assaulted another gay furry at
a furry convention. >> Unfortunate. Unlucky. >> Yeah,
you can't make this up. These are the people that exist. They're
all >> You really You really can't make it up. It's really
It's >> They're all disgusting. They're low IQ. They're
desperate for some sort of meaning or validation in their life.
And we've seen it over and over and over and
and then they look to other people to try to fill that void.
But it's not about actually caring about it. Because if it were
caring about the worst of the worst, why are these people still
not going after Keles for what Ke did Keles did with the cowboy
ranch?
No, they don't give a [__] about that. >> Just
infinite infinite endless what aboutism. Very cool. Very very
very cool. They don't give a [__] about that.
It's all what is opportunistic. They didn't care about the Epstein
files until Trump was an officer. All of a sudden, they care.
>> Rean Ruben donated $3. That's
>> Thank you very much, Ren Ruben, for the three. Thank
you so much. >> It's just performative.
>> Fantastic stuff. >> There's no morality behind
it. There's no intelligence behind it. It's just lemming behavior
and it's gross. And I've seen it in real time. These people
I I had a conversation with with somebody named Dickers. He DM'd
me.
Dickers.
We heard of that guy. We might cover that guy's How long did
anyone get a clock in on that Chudlo Logic Dickers argument earlier
by the way? Was that 6 hours, 8 hours, 12 hours? It seemed to
be
like all of the time. I swear to God, I like woke up this morning,
I saw they were talking and then like four hours later I went
live and they were still talking. It was crazy.
He asked me a question like, "Hey, do you want to come on the
show and talk about Tech?" And I said, "No."
Immediately in in that same stream, like within 10 minutes, I
had people coming into my stream. Why you running from dickers?
Why? Like the guy literally leaked the conversation within like
the span of like 10 minutes
>> because that's what these people do. They have no honor.
They have no integrity. They have no class.
>> I mean, he might have been live. Like, what if he was
live and then he saw that this guy was live and he didn't like
what he was saying and then he messaged him while saying that's
what he was doing on stream. Is that is that lacking in integrity?
>> It's just it is
>> welcome back to the stream. Dickers.
Okay. Welcome. Hello.
Glad to see you were here. Kind of not chatting until he was
mentioned, but that's concerning
Can we can we get a name change? As soon as you can do a name
change, could we just get a a name change to Dicker's tech tone?
I feel like that would drive home the point and be toss friendly
on all platforms. They're gross. They disgust me.
And they always look for some Well, you're not as good as you
think you are. Being a Christian, you understand that we're all
born into sin.
We're all born fallen. If not for Jesus Christ and his ultimate
sacrifice, we would be doomed to hell.
It's not about being better than anyone.
It's about recognizing
what's wrong and then doing what you can to not continuously
emulate that behavior
to grow and to learn and adapt.
These people don't. They they sit in the same quagmire of their
life over and over. And the only thing that they're looking for,
the only thing that a loser like this is looking for is one thing,
something to let them forget what a loser they are.
They want some debate,
some dialogue, some moment. I'm going to own this guy and then
everything's going to come up me. No.
There's a reason you will always be a gross, niche little weirdo.
because none of the content that you make is ever going to be
appealing
to anyone beyond
>> Wow. Okay. I listen, I've heard enough. He's going to
watch the legal mindset video while the doxing happens. He's
going to pretend that's a good video. It's not a good video.
I started taking notes last night while we were watching it.
So, we watched in the Patreon call. I started taking notes and
then it just like the whole thing was falling apart. I thought
about doing like some clipped up stuff and and reacting to clips
tonight. I maybe should have, but I just I don't know. I ended
up playing I ended up playing Rivals last night,
Oh, was it? It was just wrong. And almost all of the content
he covers is from the Frame Pink Chu
civil case that was filed by Pinky Chu because she thought Frame
posted revenge of her and then she took that case back.
She literally like Pinky withdrew the case. So, I don't know
why he went over a withdrawn case from like three years ago,
two two years ago. He went over that and talked about how badly
Framed Teone over and how like Frame cheated on Tech and it's
like, bro, that has nothing to do with this case. You're literally
just trying to build sympathy for Tee. It just it makes no sense.
It was a It was goofy as, man. And also,
I think Pinky Chu had been like responding to and and
like she was trying to defend Teone in that stuff. So, it was
like using her words from that civil case where I think she had
the wrong impression of what Frame did. That's my understanding.
He was using those words to try to say, "Well, no, Pikachu didn't
hate this guy. Pinky Chu was okay with this guy." It's like,
dude, what are you doing, man? I don't know what you're What
are you going for, dog? It's just bizarre. Weird stuff. Okay.